Their capital is completely round. They call it the naval of the earth, and that's what it looks like. In the middle is a huge temple, the centre of their faith. The walls were plated with gold, enough to blind us. Inside, set out on tables, golden platters for the sun to dine off. Outside the garden, acres of gold soil, planted with gold maize, entire apple trees in gold, gold, gold birds on the branches, gold geese and ducks, gold butterflies. in the air on silver strings. And imagine this. Away in a field, life-sized, 20 golden llamas grazing with their kids. The Garden of the Sun at Kusko.
他们的首都是完全圆形的。他们称之为“大地的肚脐”，看起来确实如此。中心是一座巨大的神庙，是他们信仰的核心。墙壁上镀满了黄金，足以让我们目眩。里面摆放着桌子，上面放着供太阳神用餐的金盘子。花园外，几英亩的土地上种着金色的玉米，整棵苹果树都是金子做的，树枝上有金色的鸟儿、金色的鹅和鸭子，还有银线上悬挂的金蝴蝶。想象一下，在远处的田野里，有20只真人大小的金色美洲驼带着幼崽在吃草。这就是库斯科的太阳花园。
A wonder of the earth. Look at it now. So that was Posh boy Anando de Soto in Peter Schaffer's play, The Royal Hunt of the Sun. Came out in 1964. We've been hearing a lot from it. And DeSoto, in that passage,
大地的奇迹。看看现在的它。刚才那是彼得·谢弗的戏剧《太阳的皇家狩猎》中波什男孩阿南多·德·索托的台词。该剧于1964年上映。我们已经听了很多关于它的内容。而德·索托在这一段中，
is describing one of the great wonders of the world in the early 16th century, which was Corricancha, the temple of the sun in Cusco. And Dominic, that is from a play. But Peter Schaffer, I mean, he loves his research, doesn't he? He's obviously gone to the primary sources and rework them. It's very, very closely based on some primary sources that were here from later in this episode. They were written by Spanish chroniclers a few years after the fall of the Inkers. And that sense, I mean, you did it in a sense.
描述了16世纪初世界的一大奇迹，即库斯科的太阳神庙——科里坎查。多米尼克，那是一部戏剧。但彼得·谢弗，我的意思是，他热爱研究，不是吗？他显然查阅了原始资料并进行了重写。它非常、非常紧密地基于本集后面会提到的原始资料。它们是由印加帝国灭亡几年后的西班牙编年史家撰写的。那种感觉，我的意思是，你刚才确实表现出来了。
sort of very clipped 1950s war film voice but I think generally when people perform that play there's a sense of wonder and awe
那种非常简短的20世纪50年代战争电影的语调，但我认为通常人们表演那部戏时，会有一种惊奇和敬畏的感觉，
in their voices Well should I go back and redo it No no no one wants that Their capital is completely round They call it The Naval of the Earth
在他们的声音里。好吧，我要回去重做一遍吗？不，不，没人想那样。他们的首都是完全圆形的。他们称之为“大地的肚脐”。
Oh And that's what it looks like How about that Yeah Have I got the part Definitely Definitely Gold geese and ducks
哦，看起来确实如此。怎么样？是啊。我演得怎么样？绝对，绝对。金色的鹅和鸭子。
very toast 20 golden lamas it's very toast of London that reading Matt Berry would do a very good job right yes so and actually while he's speaking in that voice loads of Indian porters in the play
非常像《伦敦生活》里的那种朗读，马特·贝里会做得很好，对吧？是的，实际上当他用那种声音说话时，剧中有大量的印第安搬运工，
I'd say Indian in inverted commas because that's what they're called in the play they've been removing the rays of the sun which are like petals and piling them up in this giant horde of loot for the Spaniards and this is what we talked about last time, the pillaging of the Temple of the Sun
我会用引号说“印第安人”，因为剧中就是这样称呼他们的，他们一直在拆除太阳的光芒，那些光芒就像花瓣一样，把它们堆成一堆巨大的战利品给西班牙人，这就是我们上次谈到的，对太阳神庙的掠夺，
to pile up Ato Alper's ransom. So he ended with Atowalpa being grotted by the Spanish anyway. So this is paranoid atmosphere in Kakamaika, where since November 1532, Pizarro and his comrades have been holding Attawalpa prisoner. And this is just the beginning
为了堆积阿塔瓦尔帕的赎金。所以他最终还是被西班牙人勒死了。所以这就是卡哈马卡的偏执气氛，自1532年11月以来，皮萨罗和他的同伙一直把阿塔瓦尔帕关押为囚犯。而这仅仅是开始，
of the looting of Peru, because this is the story of one of the greatest gold heists, surely actually the greatest gold heist in history. The, surely. I mean, I can't think of anything comparable. And at the heart of the story are the temples and treasure houses
对秘鲁的掠夺，因为这是历史上最伟大的黄金抢劫案之一，肯定就是历史上最伟大的黄金抢劫案。肯定。我的意思是，我想不出有什么可比的。故事的核心是印加圣城库斯科的神庙和宝库。所以今天的故事是关于史诗规模的黄金和贪婪。但还有更多。我们将讲述秘鲁征服史上最伟大的阵地战，涉及数万名战士。
of the Inca's holy city of Kusko. So it's a story today of gold and greed on an epic scale. But there is more. We'll be telling the story of the greatest pitched battle in the history of the conquest of Peru, so tens of thousands of warriors.
因为老实说，我们还没讲到任何战斗，对吧？不，我认为人们渴望一场战斗，他们会如愿以偿的。我们将见到一位可怕的印加军阀，他把受害者变成了打击乐器。我们喜欢那种把受害者变成打击乐器的印加军阀。其余的都是历史了。而且最令人兴奋的是，这对长期听众来说是一份真正的礼物。我们应该欢迎我们最喜欢的角色之一、顶级吉尔斯和红裤子模特佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多回到节目中。
Because to be honest, we haven't had any yet, have we? No, and I think people are gagging for a battle and they're going to get one. We'll be meeting a terrifying Inca warlord who turns his victims into percussion instruments. We love an Inca Warlord who turns its victims
真是个好家伙。绝对的传奇。所以这值得期待。那么让我们从卡哈马卡的皮萨罗和征服者开始吧。那是1534年的夏天。他们刚刚杀死了阿塔瓦尔帕。现在怎么办？
into percussion instruments. On the rest is history. And most exciting. And this is a real gift for long-standing listeners. We should be welcoming back to the show one of our favorite characters, top Gilles and Red Trousers model, Pedro de Alvarado.
所以，杀死阿塔瓦尔帕在几个方面让他们的生活变得简单多了。首先，他们现在可以自由地向库斯科进军去夺取黄金，那里距离南方大约750到800英里。这对皮萨罗的合伙人迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗来说尤其重要，正如我们上次听到的，他因为被排除在赎金分配之外而怒不可遏。气急败坏。他个子不高，穿着非常花哨，是个爱吹牛的人，而且正如我们将看到的，是个暴力的人。其次，西班牙人现在已经明确站在了阿塔瓦尔帕和瓦斯卡之间的内战的一方。
Bloody good bloke. Total ledge. So that's something to look forward to. So let's begin with Pizarra and the Conquistadors in Kachamaka. It's the summer of 1534. They've just killed Atta Walper. What now?
起初他们支持阿塔瓦尔帕，但通过杀死他，皮萨罗非常坚定地站在了代表库斯科和帝国南部的已故瓦斯卡一边。他通过选择新的傀儡皇帝进一步巩固了这一点。所以他们一直把瓦斯卡的弟弟图帕克·瓦尔帕关在卡哈马卡。他可能才20多岁，我们对他几乎一无所知。这家伙一直就在某个地方晃荡。一旦阿塔瓦尔帕被处决，他们为阿塔瓦尔帕举行了基督教葬礼并埋葬了他，皮萨罗就召集了所有当地酋长，并揭开了这个家伙——图帕克·瓦尔帕的面纱。
So, killing Atta Walper has made their life much simpler in a couple of respects. First of all, they are now free to push on for the gold of Kusko, which is about 750 miles, 800 miles to the south. And this is especially important for Pizarro's partner Diego Diomagro, who, as we heard last time, is absolutely seething because he's been cut out of the ransom. Hopping mad. He's a short man, a very colourfully dressed man, a boastful man, and, as we'll see, a violent man. Secondly, the Spaniards have definitively now taken a side in the civil war between Atahualpa and Huasca.
他们为他举行了一种加冕仪式。有很多有趣的部落舞蹈，羽毛服装也发挥了作用。我很高兴地说。所以他们没有皈依基督教？没有。实际上，西班牙人，这个故事真的很有趣，与征服墨西哥有点不同。在这个阶段，他们并没有真正做出太大的努力去强加基督教并铲除当地的，
Now, initially they were pro-Ato-Welper, but by killing him, Pizarro has put himself very firmly on the side of the late Huasca who represented Cuscoe and the south of the empire. and he cements this further with his choice of the new puppet emperor. So they have been holding in Khachemaka all this time, Huasca's younger brother, who is called Tupac Hualpa. He's probably in his 20s, we know virtually nothing about him. This bloke's just been hanging around somewhere. And as soon as Attawalpa, they've held their Christian funeral service for Attawalpa and buried him, Pizarro summons all the local chiefs, and he unveils this bloke, Tupac Hualpa.
崇拜等等。我想可能是因为他们的人数太少了，他们知道如果尝试的话简直是疯了。一切都是为了黄金。有一个很大的区别，因为你记得在征服阿兹特克人时，西班牙人总是走进神庙，对当地的偶像表现得很粗鲁。
And they have a kind of coronation ceremony for him. There's a lot of interesting tribal dancing and feathered costumes play a part. I'm happy to say. So they haven't converted to Christianity? No. And actually, the Spaniards, it's really interesting actually this story, a little bit different from the conquest of Mexico. They don't really make that much efforts to impose Christianity and to stamp out the local
嗯，还有，当时存在人祭，我认为这可能加剧了文化差异感。也许吧。西班牙人总的来说不喜欢文化差异。实际上，在加冕仪式后，对当地酋长来说，
cults and whatnot at this stage. I think probably because they're so heavily outnumbered, and they know it would be madness to even try. It's all about the gold. There's a big difference, because you remember in the conquest of the Aztecs, the Spaniards are always kind of going into temples and being rude about the local idols and stuff.
你可以看出他们认为自然秩序现在已经恢复了。瓦斯卡的家族重新掌权了。他的兄弟是新皇帝。是的，他有这些为他工作的奇怪的外国雇佣兵。但你可以看出他们是如何在整个帝国推销这一点的。
Well, also, there was human sacrifice going on, and I think that that possibly intensifies the sense of cultural difference. Maybe, yeah. They're not fans of cultural difference, so they're the Spaniards by and large. And actually, to the local chiefs, after the coronation service,
所以这有点像公元5世纪的罗马意大利，有一个被哥特卫队包围的无能的罗马皇帝。完全是这样。而且，你知道，我在录制上一集时确实想到了这一点。与那种为你工作的蛮族雇佣兵的相似之处。
you can see that they think basically the natural order now has been restored. Huasca's family are back in charge. His brother is the new emperor. Yes, he's got these weird foreign mercenaries who are working for him. But you can see how they could sell that across the empire.
而区别当然在于，西班牙人会以压倒性的数量到来，我想。此外，他们没有任何成为印加人的愿望。正是如此。所以这是另一个巨大的区别。是的。在西班牙人的世界里，没有地方让你容忍印加人的崇拜和神灵，
So it's kind of like Roman Italy in the 5th century AD with an ineffectual Roman emperor surrounded by Gothic guards. Completely. And that's, you know, I actually thought about that in the last, while we're recording the last episode. The parallel with kind of barbarian murks.
例如，而德国雇佣兵，他们都变成了基督徒。嗯，德国雇佣兵在某种程度上想成为罗马人，不是吗？而西班牙人根本没有成为秘鲁人的愿望。没有。实际上，在这次加冕仪式结束时，图帕克·瓦尔帕礼节性地给了皮萨罗这个白羽毛头饰，
who are working for you. And the difference, of course, is that the Spanish are going to come in such overwhelming numbers, I suppose. Also, that they feel no aspiration to become an Inca. Exactly. So that's the other big difference. Yeah. There's no place in the Spanish world for you to tolerate the cults and the gods,
并说这是对我领主查理五世的贡品。这是这种动态中权力真正所在的一个标志。现在，在许多关于印加帝国灭亡的记载中，故事到这里就结束了。阿塔瓦尔帕死了，西班牙人得到了黄金，西班牙人有了傀儡皇帝，西班牙人赢了。所以他们没有提到……那个基于打击乐的。是的。你还记得你童书里的那个吗？我不记得了。
for instance, of the Inca, whereas the German mercenaries, they all became Christian. Well, the German mercenaries want to become Romans, don't they, to some degree? Whereas the Spanish have no desire to become Peruvians. No. And actually, at the end of this coronation ceremony, Tupac Qualpa gives Pizarro ceremonially this white feathered headdress
因为它会成为一个精彩的插图，我们正在抢先剧透节目。那会是的。那会是的。我的意思是，那会非常棒。大多数童书都是在这里结束的。对于皮萨罗的一些手下来说，这就是终点。所以他允许他们带着战利品回到西班牙。他的兄弟阿南多当然已经走了。他于1534年1月抵达塞维利亚，当他卸下黄金时，引起了巨大的轰动。
and says this is a tribute to my overlord Charles V. And that is a sign of where power really lies in this dynamic. Now, in a lot of accounts of the fall of the Inkers, this is when the story ends. Atualpa is dead, the Spanish of the gold, the Spanish of a puppet emperor, the Spanish of Wom. So they finish without any mention of the... the percussion based. Yeah. Do you remember that from your children's book? I don't.
当他在塞维利亚卸货时，印度群岛委员会立即写信给查理五世，说你必须在宫廷里欢迎这个人，你必须看看这个。阿南多被邀请到托莱多的宫廷。他成了一个巨大的名人。每个人都非常兴奋。然后他去了皮萨罗的祖籍地埃斯特雷马杜拉，并进行了一次招募活动以获得更多的人。
Because it would have made a brilliant illustration and we're preempting the show. It would have been. It would have been. I mean, it would have been tremendous. This is where most of the children's books end. And for some of Pizarro's men, this is the end. So he gives them permission to go back to Spain with their winnings. His brother, Anando, has already gone, of course. He reached Seville in January 1534. and his gold was a huge sensation when he unloaded it.
你可以来拿黄金。我们为什么不一起去呢？与此同时，另外两个回去的人，克里斯托瓦尔·德·梅纳和弗朗西斯科·赫雷斯，写了他们在秘鲁的经历，按16世纪的标准，这些书成了巨大的畅销书。它们被翻译成了意大利语和德语。
When he unloaded it in Seville, the council of the Indies immediately wrote to Charles V and said, you've got to welcome this guy at court, you've got to see this. Anando was invited to the court in Toledo. He was a massive celebrity. Everyone was very excited. He then went to Extra Madura to the Pizarro's kind of ancestral homeland, and he went on a recruitment drive to get more people.
威尼斯的人们，威尼斯的地图绘制者，开始制作各种秘鲁的想象地图。这基本上成了一种巨大的轰动，如果你年轻，如果你自认为是冒险家，秘鲁就是你现在要去的地方。我认为从那一刻起，印加人显然注定要灭亡，因为未来几年会有更多的人乘船抵达。
You can come and get gold. Why don't we all go? And meanwhile, two of the other guys who returned, Christobald de Meña and Francisco Hereth, they wrote accounts of their time in Peru, which became, by the standards of the 16th century, huge bestsellers. And they were translated into Italian and into German.
所以这是一个非常熟悉的故事，不是吗，关于征服西部，美洲的原住民一旦闻到黄金的味道，他们就注定要灭亡？是的，淘金热开始了，正是如此。所以只有一个问题。你认为是否存在一个印加人幸存下来的替代现实？如果他们击退了皮萨罗，如果他们对这种可能性保持警惕，如果他们有了马匹，如果他们获得了武器？是的。
And people in Venice, mapmakers in Venice, started producing sort of imaginary maps of Peru. And it became this great sensation, basically if you're young, if you fancy yourself as an adventurer, Peru is where you now go. And I think from that moment onwards, clearly the Inca's are doomed because a lot more people are going to arrive by ship in the next few years.
你认为他们能足够快且足够充分地升级他们的基础设施以击退西班牙征服者吗？不，内心深处，因为，我的意思是，美洲没有人能做到。但也许印加人比任何人都更有可能，因为他们太孤立了，太难到达了。是的，我认为地形实际上使得你可以想象某种安第斯高地国家幸存下来，只是很难到达。所以低地被征服了，但海岸线总是，
So it's the very familiar story, isn't it, of the winning of the West, that Native peoples in the Americas once there's a sniff of gold, they're doomed? Yeah, the gold rushes on, exactly. So just one question. Do you think there is an alternative reality where the Inca's do survive? Had they seen off Pizarro, had they become alert to the possibility, had they got horses, had they obtained weapons? Yeah.
西班牙人总是会来，但也许，你知道，所以印加人确实缺少几样东西，真的，如果当时有的话可能会是一个巨大的改变者，那就是弓箭。因为安第斯山脉没有那么多树，
Do you think that they could have upgraded their infrastructure fast enough and sufficiently enough to sea off Spanish conquerors? No, deep down, because, I mean, nobody in the Americas does it. But maybe the Inca's more than anyone else because they're so isolated, so hard to get to. Yes, I think the terrain actually makes it perfectly possible you could imagine. I would say some sort of Andean highland state surviving, just hard to get to. So the lowlands being conquered, but the coastline always,
他们几乎没有长矛和弓箭，这可能有助于击倒马匹。我的意思是，这很神奇，正如我们将在本集中提到的。你知道，少数马匹就能击退成百上千名惊恐万状且不知道如何击倒它们的人，因为他们没有多少弓箭。但如果他们有足够的喘息空间，他们可能已经学会了。是的，反驳的观点是，大陆上没有其他地方的人能坚持住。
the Spanish are always coming, but maybe, you know, so the Inkers don't have a couple of things, really, something that might have been a massive gain changer if then is a bow and arrow. Because they don't have that many trees in the Andes,
以及西班牙技术、数量和疾病的压力。我的意思是，有一件事我们没有真正多谈，我们在第一集谈过，天花已经登场，并且在西班牙人到达之前就已经造成了影响，疾病将继续摧毁南美洲的人口。好吧，所以这对印加人来说基本上是个坏消息。是的。
they have remarkably few kind of pikes and bows and arrows, which might have helped bring down the horses. I mean, it's amazing, as we'll come to in this episode. you know, a handful of horses can see off hundreds and hundreds of men who are terrified and they don't know
所以回到卡哈马卡，皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗正准备向南出发。这真的，即使按他们自己的标准，这也是一段绝对疯狂的旅程。他们要向南穿过中部安第斯山脉大约800英里。他们基本上一直在上下起伏。下到这些山谷，穿过河流，攀登这些山峰。正如约翰·赫明在他那本精彩的书中说的那样，这是历史上最令人震惊的入侵之一。没有补给、通讯或增援，
how to bring them down because they don't have many bows and arrows. But they might have learned, if they'd had a sufficient breathing space, they might have. Yeah, the counter argument to that is nowhere else on the continent to people hold out.
这支小分队试图强行进入一个巨大的敌对帝国的中心，夺取其首都。他们于8月11日出发。这非常像亚历山大大帝穿过现在的土耳其、伊朗等地。无尽的河流穿越、绳桥、攀爬岩壁、
And the weight of Spanish technology of numbers and also disease. I mean, one thing we haven't really talked about much, we talked about in the first episode, Smallpox has made its entrance and has, before the Spaniards even arrived, and disease will continue to decimate the populations of South America. Okay, so it's bad news for the incomes, basically. Yeah.
被陌生人伏击，所有这些事情。总之，经过大约八周的跋涉，进展其实相当顺利。所以他们大约走了一半，我认为这已经很不错了。当地人大多是瓦斯卡的支持者。是的，所以这就是万卡人。是的，所以有万卡人支持总是好的。
So back in Kachamaka, Pizarro and Al-Magro are preparing to set off south. And this really, I mean, even by their own standards, this is an absolutely insane journey to be doing. They're going 800 miles almost south across the central Andes. They're basically going up and down the whole time. down into these valleys, crossing rivers, climbing these peaks. As John Heming says in his brilliant book, it's one of the most staggering invasions in history. Without supplies, communications or reinforcements,
我想你总是能得到他们的支持，对吧，汤姆，万卡人？我想他们非常支持汤姆·霍兰德。我永远不会冷落万卡人。不。所以到10月初，西班牙人正在接近绍沙山谷。这就是阿南多·皮萨罗引诱查尔库奇马去的地方。那个橄榄球运动员。他被烧死了。
this tiny contingent was going to try to force its way into the heart of an enormous hostile empire to seize its capital city. And they set off on the 11th of August. It's very like Alexander the Great kind of going through what's now, you know, Turkey, Iran and whatnot. Sort of endless river crossing. rope bridges, climbing rock faces,
是的，他被烧死了。而且实际上，他还活着，不是吗？西班牙人把他带在身边。如果你还记得的话，他被烧得很严重。我想他的肌腱被严重烧伤了，不是吗？他们现在把他锁了起来，但他们把他带在身边。现在大约在这个时候，所以中途，
ambushes by strange people, all of this kind of thing. Anyway, after about eight weeks of this, it's actually going pretty well. So they're about halfway, which I think is really good going. The locals, by and large, are Hwaska supporters. Well, these are the wanker people. Yes, so it's always good to have the wankers on side.
西班牙人开始变得非常紧张。侦察兵报告说有北方军队。所以那是阿塔瓦尔帕的前军队。来自北方基多的军队就在附近。这些军队由北方指挥官基斯基斯领导，
I think you've always got them on side, haven't you, Tom, the wankers? They're very much team Tom Holland, I think. I would never snub a wanker. No. So by early October, the Spaniards are approaching the valley of Shaosha. So this is where Enando Pizarro lured away Chalcuchima. The rugby player. He got burnt.
就是那个为阿塔瓦尔帕夺取库斯科的人。总之，西班牙人继续前进。地形变得更加荒凉。现在非常冷。一些西班牙人不出所料地患上了严重的高原反应。
Yes, he got burnt. And actually, he's still alive, isn't he? The Spaniards have brought him with them. He's very badly singed, if you may recall. His tendons, I think, had been badly burned, aren't he? And they've now chained him up, but they've brought him with them. Now at about this point So the halfway
你知道他们有几万英尺高。村庄荒无人烟，有更多关于北方军队的传言，最后他们来到了绍沙山谷，那里还有两个关于内战的提醒。所以首先，非常不祥的是，我的意思是，我知道我们对阿兹特克人也这么说过，
The Spaniards start to get very jittery The scouts are reporting There are northern troops So that's Attawalpa's former armies The troops from Quito in the north Are nearby And these are led by the northern commander Kiskeskis
但这将是另一部精彩的好莱坞电影或系列。他们骑马经过几个月前被基多军队杀死的4000人的尸体，尸体被留在那里腐烂。然后，当他们继续前进时，当地人开始出来迎接他们作为解放者。我引用一下，“土著们都来到路上看基督徒，并热烈庆祝他们的到来，因为他们认为这意味着他们可以从那支外国军队的奴役中解脱出来。”
Who is the guy who had taken Kusko for Attawalpa Anyway the Spaniards go on The terrain becomes more desolate It's now very cold And some of the Spanish Not surprisingly have got terrible Altitude sickness
外国军队，也就是印加人。是的，是一支来自厄瓜多尔北部基多的印加军队。西班牙人进入绍沙，发现北方人留下了600人去放火烧仓库。西班牙人发起冲锋，赶走了北方人，并抢救了一些黄金。然后有一点追逐，西班牙人基本上在追赶北方军队的后卫穿过这个山谷。这显然是许多小片段中的一个，你得到了这个小片段，背后隐藏着一个我们不知道的更大的故事。追击持续了四里格，许多印第安人被长矛刺死。我们带走了所有的仆人和许多美丽的女人。
You know there are tens of thousands of feet high up. The villages are deserted, there are more rumours of northern troops, and at last they come out in the valley of Shaosha, and there are two more reminders of the Civil War. So first, very ominously, I mean, I know we said this with the Aztecs,
那里有大量的黄金和白银。就在这些话中，“我们带走了所有的仆人和许多美丽的女人”。你不必太愤世嫉俗就能想象那些美丽的女人所遭遇的命运一点也不愉快。可能有很多这样的事情在幕后发生。现在，在这一切期间，当西班牙人可能表现得非常糟糕时，一个完全意想不到的发展发生了。在旅途中，年轻的皇帝，傀儡皇帝，图帕克·瓦尔帕病倒了，
but this would be another brilliant Hollywood film or series. They ride past the bodies of 4,000 people who'd been killed by the Keaton army some months earlier, and the bodies have been left there to rot. And then, as they continue, the locals start to turn out and to greet them as liberators. I quote, the natives all came out onto the road to look at the Christians and greatly celebrated their arrival, for they thought it would mean their escape from the servitude in which they were held by that foreign army.
我们完全不知道他得了什么病。不是有传言说查尔库奇马毒死了他吗？是的，我想几乎肯定是胡说八道。我认为这是……抹黑他名字的一部分。我的意思是，抹黑，他已经被抹黑了，记得吗？是的。但现在他们正在隐喻地抹黑他。
The foreign army, which is the Inca's. Yeah, is an Inca army from Quito, in Ecuador, from the north. The Spanish go into Zhaosha, and they find that the northerners have left behind 600 men to set fire to the storehouses. It's the Spanish charge, they drive off the northerners, and they save some of the gold. And then there's a bit of a chase, as the Spanish are chasing basically the rear guard of the Northern Army through this valley. And this is clearly one of many little, you get this little snippet, behind which lies a much bigger story that is unknown to us. The pursuit continued for four leagues and many Indians were speared. We took all the serving people and many beautiful women.
是的，所以图帕克·瓦尔帕突然基本上病倒了，然后他死了。这对皮萨罗来说是个坏消息，因为他失去了他的傀儡皇帝。他召集了所有当地的大人物。他说，好吧，现在谁应该是皇帝？有些人说有一个叫曼科的瓦斯卡的兄弟，他在库斯科。其他人说，不，不，他不行。找一个阿塔瓦尔帕的儿子。他们无法达成一致，基本上陷入了僵局，暂时没有决定。
there was a good haul of both gold and silver. And just in those words, we took all the serving people and many beautiful women. You don't have to be too cynical to imagine that what the fate that befalls the many beautiful women is not a pleasant one at all. There's probably a lot of this stuff happening offstage. Now, during all this, when the Spanish had probably behaving very badly, a wholly unexpected development. During the journey, the young emperor, puppet emperor, Tupac Hualpa, has fallen ill.
所以我把这个想法留在这里，悬而未决。那里有一个真空。与此同时，西班牙人正在为行军的最后一段做准备，这是最戏剧性的部分，即穿过中部安第斯山脉前往库斯科。这真的是那种，你知道，绳桥、悬崖、不可能的岩壁，所有这些事情。所以皮萨罗的秘书佩德罗·桑乔对这些山路攀登中的许多次有记载。
and we have no idea whatsoever what he fell ill with. Isn't there a rumour that Chalkachima had poisoned him? Yes, I think almost certainly rubbish. I think this is part of the... The blackening of his name. I mean, the blackening, he's already blackened, remember? Yeah. But now they're blackening him metaphorically.
从下面向上看，似乎鸟儿飞过空中都无法攀登，更不用说骑马的人在陆地上攀爬了。然而，他们带着所有的土著搬运工和随军家属等等做到了。在他们到达库斯科之前的最后一个山口，还有两次与基多军队的小规模冲突，他们仍然在维尔卡斯瓦曼和维尔卡孔加徘徊。
Yeah, so Tubaqualpa suddenly basically falls ill and then he dies. And this is very bad news for Pizarro, because he's lost his puppet emperor. And he summons all the local bigwigs. And he says, well, who should be the emperor now? And some people say there's some bloke who's a brother of Huasca who's called Manco, who's off in Kusko. And other people say, no, no, he's no good. Get one of Atalpa's sons. And they can't agree and there's basically a stalemate and there's no decision for the time being.
但两次，尽管西班牙人处于劣势，他们还是设法击退了攻击者。有趣的问题是为什么印加人无法击败西班牙人，因为他们的人数远远超过他们。嗯，因为当你说是印加人时，是的。我的意思是，这具体是指北方的印加人，对吧？是的，基多人，我想我们应该这样称呼他们。
So I leave that thought, that hanging. There's a vacuum there. Meanwhile, the Spanish are preparing for the last section of the march, which is the most dramatic bit, which is crossing the central Andes towards Kuzko. And this is real kind of, you know, rope bridge, clans. impossible cliff faces, all of this kind of thing. So there's a account by Pedro Sancho Pizarro's secretary on one of many of these mountain ascents.
所以这只是印加人的一小部分。确实，但可能有30,000人。他们有南方印加人，他们有万卡人。是的，好吧，他们有至关重要的土著支持。所以这不是西班牙人对阵印加人。这是西班牙人和印加帝国的一半对阵另一半。这是一回事。我想你是完全正确的。
Looking up at it from below, it seemed impossible for birds to scale it by flying through the air, let alone men on horseback climbing by land. And yet they do it with all their kind of native porters and, you know, camp followers and stuff. There are two more skirmishes with the Keaton army who are still hanging around at a place called Vilkas Hwauman and Vilka Conga.
然后另一件事是马匹。所有的记载都说，少数骑兵即使在相当崎岖的地形中也能击退成百上千甚至数千名印加人。西班牙人开始在西班牙获得这种令人敬畏的名声。你知道，在这一点上，我想没有一个西班牙人被杀，这太不可思议了。那确实不可思议，不是吗？是的。但我猜如果他们没有长矛，没有弓箭，你怎么能阻止一匹马？对。
But both times, although the Spanish are outnumbered, they managed to drive their attackers back. And the interesting question is why the Inca's are not able to defeat the Spaniards, because they massively outnumber them. Well, because when you say Inkers, yeah. I mean, it's specifically the Inkers from the North, right? Yes, the Keetans, as I guess we should call them.
你有一种棍子之类的东西。我的意思是，你可能会幸运地击中一下。那那种两端有石头、中间有绳子的东西呢，你扔出去？哦，是的。它们缠住马蹄并把它们绊倒。如果是我，我会那样做。是的，是的，正是如此。在电影里，他们会那样做。
So it's only a faction of the Inkers. It is, but there's maybe 30,000 of them. They've got the Southern Inkers and they've got the Wanker. Yeah, well, they've got native support that's absolutely crucial. So this isn't Spanish versus Incas. It's Spanish and half of the Inca Empire against the other half. That's one thing. I think you're dead right.
我的意思是，那将是极好的弹弓动作。我的意思是，他们确实有弹弓，但他们从来没能击倒这些人。所以我们现在到了1533年11月，现在一个极其重要的人物进入了这个故事。所以，在维尔卡孔加最后一次小规模冲突后的一两天，一群当地人接近了西班牙营地。其中一个人，我引用一下，“看起来像个普通的印第安人”，我的意思是，显然在整个故事中，西班牙人称当地人为印第安人。他表明了自己的身份，他说：“我是曼科。我是已故瓦斯卡的弟弟。我是已故皇帝瓦伊纳·卡帕克的儿子。”
And then the other thing is the horses. All the accounts say that a handful of horsemen would even in quite hilly terrain could see off hundreds, even thousands of Inkers. And the Spanish start to get this reputation for really awe in Spain. You know, at this point, I think no Spaniard has been killed, which is incredible. That is incredible, isn't it? Yeah. But I suppose if they haven't got pikes and they haven't got bows and arrows, how do you stop a horse? Right.
“我是内战中南方派系、库斯科派系的新候选人。”他多大了？我们不太清楚。一些西班牙人说他15岁，一些说他20岁但看起来更年轻。我们就说是十几岁吧。他已经逃亡了几个月。当阿塔瓦尔帕占领库斯科时，曼科基本上逃跑了，因为他知道如果阿塔瓦尔帕的人找到他，他必死无疑。当这个曼科出现时，皮萨罗很高兴。
You've got a kind of club or something. I mean, you might get a lucky blow in. What about one of those pieces of string with stones on either end and you throw them? Oh, yes. And they go round the hooves and bring them down. That's what I would do. Yeah, yeah, exactly. In a film, that's what they would have.
他对曼科说：“我来这里只有一个原因，就是把你从基多人的奴役中解放出来。知道他们对你造成的伤害，我想阻止他们，我想把库斯科人民从这种暴政中解放出来。”所以他通过翻译说了这些话。曼科似乎相信了，说：“哦，太棒了，好吧，我们可以合作。”
I mean, they would be excellent slingshot action. I mean, they do have slings, but they're just never able to bring any of these people down. So we're now up to November 1533, and now a massively important figure enters this story. So a day or so after the last skirmish at Vilco Conga, a group of locals approached the Spanish camp. And one of them, and I quote, looking like a common Indian, I mean, obviously all through this story, the Spanish called the locals Indians. He identifies himself and he says, I am Manco. I am the younger brother of the late Huasca. I'm a son of the late emperor Hwena Capac.
“这就是我想要的。”哦，我太高兴了。我们知道曼科不是白痴，是一个钢铁般的人，因为他立刻展现了他的钢铁意志。西班牙人一直拖着那个叫查尔库奇马的家伙。现在曼科在他们面前与查尔库奇马对质，他说：“我知道你一直在向基多军队、向基斯基斯和他的手下走私命令。”基本上，要么通过线人，要么大概通过你那些漂亮的绳子。
I am the new candidate of the southern faction, the Kusko faction in the Civil War. How old is we don't quite know? Some Spaniards said he was 15, some said he was 20 but looked younger. Let's say late teens. He's been on the run for months. When AtuAlpa captured Kusko, Manko had basically run away. because he knew he'd be a dead man if Atulapur's men found him. And Pizarro is delighted when this guy Manco turns up.
然后发生了一场巨大的争吵。皮萨罗失去了理智，他对着查尔库奇马大喊：“你这只狗！你怎么能耍这种卑鄙的手段？”基本上他们把查尔库奇马拖到了最近的村庄广场。他们对他说：“你知道，我们要杀了你，皈依基督教，我们就勒死你而不是烧死你。”他说：“你知道，我已经烧过了。你还不如直接完成工作。”你觉得他像加勒比海的哈图伊吗，那个说他不皈依基督教是因为他不想去一个有西班牙人的天堂的人？
And he says to Manco, I have come for one reason only to free you from slavery by the men of Quito. Knowing the injuries they were doing to you, I wanted to put stop to them, and I wanted to liberate the people of Kuzko from this tyranny. So he says this through interpreters. And Manco appears to believe it and says, oh, brilliant, well, we can work together.
是的。那种氛围。如果天堂里全是像你们这样的人，我才不去那里。正是如此。所以他们放火把他活活烧死了。实际上，一个小细节，其中一个来源说，最热心、最积极烧死他的人是他自己以前的朋友，我认为这对我们所有人都是一个教训。不要交朋友。是的。不过他死得很勇敢。他呼吁基斯基斯为他报仇。他大喊：“你知道，你有一天会为我报仇的。”实际上基斯基斯仍然带着他的军队在某个地方徘徊。在他们到达库斯科之前的最后一个山口还有一场战斗。这一次，基多军队差点打败他们。他们把西班牙人逼退了，但这是一个持续的问题。他们从来没能在天黑前彻底消灭他们。
that's all that I want. Oh, I'm so pleased. And we know that Manco is not an idiot and is a man of steel because he shows his steel right away. The Spaniards have been dragging this boat Chalcuchima around with them. And now Manco confronts Chalcuchima in front of them and he says, I know you've been smuggling orders to the Keaton army to Kiskees and his men. Basically, either through informants or presumably through your nice bits of string.
实际上，整晚西班牙人都蜷缩在一起，有点像罗克渡口的风格。当黎明到来时，基斯基斯的人不见了。他们消失在山里了。他们认为西班牙人是不可战胜的。他们有点灰心丧气了。基斯基斯现在开始带着他的军队进行这次漫长的撤退。我的意思是，几个月前还因为以为赢了内战而兴高采烈的家伙，现在开始了向北、回到厄瓜多尔的漫长撤退。
And there's a massive row. Pizarro loses the plot and he shouts at Chalcuchis. You dog! How could you pull such a navis trick? And basically they dragged Chalcuchima into the nearest village square. They say to him, you know, we're going to kill you, convert to Christianity, and we'll garrot you instead of burning you. He says, you know, I've been burned already. You might as well just finish the job. Do you think he's like Hachui, wasn't it, in the Caribbean, who said that he wouldn't convert to Christianity because he didn't want to be in a heaven where there was Spaniards?
他的人显然精疲力竭，士气正在低落，我们将看到这在本集下半部分是如何发展的。但现在，1533年11月15日星期六的早晨，皮萨罗和曼科，我想一些资料说他骑着马，这对库斯科人民来说一定是一个惊人的景象，他们作为征服者骑马进入了首都。现在库斯科，今天一个非常受欢迎的旅游目的地，是印加文明的心脏。印加人称之为“世界的肚脐”。它是帝国的政治和精神中心，在安第斯地区以其
Yeah. That kind of vibe. If heaven's full of people like you, I'm not going there. Exactly. So they set him on fire and burn him to death. Actually, a small detail, one of the sources says the people who burned him most keen and enthusiastically were his own former friends, which I think is a lesson to us all. Don't have friends. Yeah. He dies very bravely, though. He calls on Kiskes to avenge him. He shouts out, you know, you will avenge me one day. And actually Kiskees is still hanging around somewhere with his army. There's one more battle on the last. mountain pass before they get to Kusko. And this time, the Keaton army almost beats them. They drive the Spanish back, but it's a constant issue. They can never finish them off completely before nightfall.
宫殿、建筑和神庙等而闻名。所以如果你想象一下，当时的库斯科和现在一样，分布在非常肥沃、非常绿色的安第斯山谷顶部的山脚下。它当时的建筑是单层的，用石头或土坯建造，屋顶是茅草。有一个网格系统。非常干净。非常有秩序。西班牙人写信回家说，美丽的铺砌小路。中间总是有水渠。非常干净。中心是这个叫阿尔克帕塔的大广场，周围排列着印加人的宫殿。
And actually, all night the Spanish kind of hunker down, slightly Rourke's drift style. And when dawn comes, Kiskes' men are nowhere to be seen. They've melted away into the mountains. They think the Spanish can't be beaten. And they've slightly lost heart. And Kiskees now begins this long retreat with his army. I mean, the guy who a few months earlier was on Cloud 9 because he thought he'd won the Civil War, he starts this long retreat towards the north, back to Ecuador.
所以基本上，每个印加人，每个皇帝，在生前都会建造一座宫殿或豪宅。这将是他自己的陵墓，他自己的安息之地。当他死后，他木乃伊化的尸体会被放在这座宫殿里，带着他所有的家具、所有的东西和他所有的老仆人。这很棒。我的意思是，实际上，你并没有死。如果他们举行某种游行，皇家婚礼或加冕典礼之类的，他们都会被带
His men are obviously knackered, and their morale is ebbing, and we will see how that plays out in the second half of this episode. But for now, the morning of Saturday, the 15th of November, 1533, Pizarro and Manco, who's, I think some of the sources say, on a horse, which must have been an amazing sight for the people of Kusko, they ride into the capital city as conquerors. Now Kusko, a very popular tourist destination today, is the heart of Inca civilization. The Inca's called it the naval of the world. It was the political and spiritual center of the empire, famous across the Andean region for its
出来，不是吗？他们都会被带出来，不是吗？他们被放在轿子里抬着到处走。他们按时间顺序排列他们。是的。所以这就像，你知道，在这里举行皇家婚礼，你会让维多利亚女王和乔治三世出来，他们都会被推出来，他们就那样坐着。
palaces and its architecture and its temples and so on and so forth. So if you imagine it, Kusko then as now is spread across the foothills at the top of this very fertile, very green Andean Valley. Its buildings then were kind of one story made of stone or adobe and they were thatched. There was a grid system. It's very clean. It's very orderly. The Spaniards wrote home and said beautiful paved little roads. They've always got water channels down the middle. It's very clean. At the center is this great square called Alke-Pata, which is lined with the palaces of of the Inca's.
那会很棒。是的。那会很棒。聊天室里的塔比正确地指出我们应该对以前的《其余都是历史》的制作人这样做。所以我们可以有西奥，把他带到这里来。我们以前的制作人，西奥·杨·史密斯，我们可以在《其余都是历史》的活动中带出他木乃伊化的尸体，
So basically, each Inca, each emperor, would build a palace or a mansion during his lifetime. And this was going to be his own mausoleum, his own resting place. And when he was dead, his mummified body would be put in this palace with all his furniture, all his stuff, and all his old servants. Which is great. Yeah. I mean, effectively, you're not dead. And if they have a kind of procession, a royal wedding or coronation or something, they're all brought
并用轿子抬着他游行。我相信每个人都会喜欢的。这是历史的教训。是的，完全是。所以西班牙人认为库斯科很棒。我能问一下吗，库斯科肯定处于一种巨大的混乱状态吧。我的意思是，每个人都死于天花，而且发生了所有这些战斗，它被讨厌它的人占领了。但问题就在这里。
out, aren't they? And they're all brought out, aren't they? And they're kind of carried around in litters. and they line them up chronologically. Yeah. So it would be like, you know, having a royal wedding here and you'd have Queen Victoria and George III and they'd all be wheeled out and they'd just kind of sit there.
显然没有。对吧？否则，他们会报告的。也许基斯基斯没有，你知道，他没有把它夷为平地，占领它的北方军队也没有留下可怕的烂摊子。我的意思是，我不知道为什么会这样。但资料会告诉我们的，不是吗？西班牙人，他们会想告诉我们的。或者也许它太超出了西班牙人对城市应该是什么样子的感觉，
That'll be great. Yeah. That would be great. Tabby in the chat correctly points out that we should do this with former Restus History producers. So we could have Theo, just bring him in here. Our erstwhile producer, Theo Young Smith, we could bring out his mummified body at Restus history events
以至于它再次让他们觉得像浪漫小说里的东西，因为那是墨西哥的一个主题，不是吗？也许吧。或者也许他们，我的意思是，所有的西班牙资料，当然，夸大这些事情总是符合他们的利益，因为他们想吸引更多的人，他们想给国王留下深刻印象。是的。
and parade it around on a litter. I'm sure everyone would enjoy that. It's lessons from history. Yeah, completely. So the Spanish thought that Kusko was brilliant. Can I just ask, surely Kusko must be in a massive state, though. I mean, everyone's died of smallpox, and there's been all this fighting, and it's been occupied by people who hate it. But here's the thing.
所以他们写信给查理五世，这座城市是印度群岛中见过的最伟大的城市。我们可以向陛下保证它非常美丽，有如此精美的建筑，即使在西班牙也会引人注目。我想值得一提的一点是，这些人都没有去过墨西哥。所以他们没有比较的标准。是的。因为它不如特诺奇蒂特兰好，我想特诺奇蒂特兰更大，更令人印象深刻。是的。
Clearly not. Right? Otherwise, they would report on it. Maybe Kiskesis has not, you know, he hasn't raised it to the ground, and the northern army that has been occupying hasn't left a terrible mess. I mean, I don't know why that is. But the sources would tell us, wouldn't they? The Spanish, they would want to tell us. Or maybe it's so outside the sense that the Spanish had of what a city should look like,
或者也许他们在秘鲁待的时间足够长，在这么多小村庄里骑马穿过，到达一个如此广阔的地方让人感到不知所措。我想这可能是对的。你知道，他们到达时当然很焦虑，在所有的战斗和卡哈马卡的事情之后，但他们很高兴。人们把他们当作解放者来迎接。他们搬进了印加人的宫殿。他们的尸体，木乃伊发生了什么？
that it strikes them again like something from a romance, because that was a theme in Mexico, wasn't it? Maybe. Yeah. Or maybe they, I mean, all the Spanish sources, of course, it's always in their interest to big these things up because they want to attract more people and they want to impress the king. Yeah.
大概还在那里？我不知道。嗯，那有点令人毛骨悚然。哦，还有皮萨罗，别忘了，皮萨罗有前科。我的意思是，他和阿塔瓦尔帕一起过夜。是的，但他还活着。我的意思是，他会和阿塔瓦尔帕的父亲一起过夜吗？一具200岁的木乃伊。
So they write to Charles V, the city's the greatest ever seen in the Indies. We can assure your majesty it's so beautiful and there's such fine buildings It would be remarkable even in Spain. I guess one point worth saying is none of these people have been to Mexico. So they've got no standard of comparison. Yeah. Because it's not as good as Tenochtitland, which is bigger, I think, and more impressive. Yeah.
和乔治三世一起，你会吗？我不知道。你知道吗？我可能会，只是为了说我为了体验而做过，不是吗？我猜。如果有人说，你想在那晚过夜吗
Or maybe they've been in Peru long enough and kind of cantering through so many small villages that arrive at somewhere this vast is kind of overwhelming. I think that's probably right. You know, they were anxious when they arrived, of course, after all the fighting and after with Chiamaka and stuff, but they are delighted. The people greet them as liberators. They move into the palaces of the Inca's. What happens to their bodies, to the mummies?
和征服者威廉一起？我的意思是，实际上他的尸体已经死了。他爆炸了。那会很可怕。是的。不，我的意思是，
Presumably still there? I don't know. Well, that's a bit creepy. Oh, and Pizarro, don't forget, Pizarro's got a form. I mean, he spent the night with Atta Welper. Yeah, but he was alive. I mean, would he spend a night with Atta Welper's father? A 200-year-old mummy.
你会选谁？我可能会选我不知道。乔治五世，我最喜欢的国王。乔治五世。我们可以谈谈集邮。那是不尊重的。
With George III, would you? I don't know. Do you know what? I probably would, just to say that I'd done it for the experience, wouldn't you? I guess. If somebody said, would you like to spend that night
但他已经死了，多米尼克。这就是重点。是的，但他会像活着一样有趣的谈话。我的意思是……
with William the Conqueror? I mean, actually his body would be dead. He exploded. That would be horrible. Yeah. No, I mean,
我想也许是查尔斯二世。是的，当然。只是为了乐趣。是的。好吧。那会感觉不那么不尊重。查尔斯一世会是一个转折，不是吗？是的，他的头会被缝上还是只是滚来滚去。
who would you choose? I would probably choose I don't know. George the 5th, my favorite king. George the 5th. We could talk about stamp collecting. Be disrespectful.
正是如此。所以他们都搬进了这些宫殿。当地人对此有何感想，我们不知道。但他们没有反抗。你知道，他们没有起义。他们没有把西班牙人赶走。没有理由怀疑他们确实把他们当作解放者来迎接。西班牙人的记载中充满了对库斯科的美丽和财富的兴奋。
But he'd be dead, Dominic. That's the point. Yeah, but he'd be about as interesting a conversation as if he was alive. I mean...
但他已经死了，多米尼克。重点就在这儿。是啊，但他活着的时候谈话也未必有多有趣。我是说……
I think maybe Charles the second. Yeah, of course. Just for the bans. Yeah. Well. It would feel less disrespectful. Charles the first would be a twist, wouldn't it? Yeah, would his head be sewn on or just rolling around.
我觉得也许是查理二世。当然了。就为了那些禁令。嗯。这样感觉没那么不敬。查理一世会是个反转，不是吗？是啊，他的头是缝上去的还是就在那儿滚来滚去？
Exactly. So they all move into these palaces. What the locals make of this, we do not know. But they don't rebel. You know, they don't rise up. They don't drive the Spanish out. There's no reason to doubt that they do greet them as liberators. The Spanish accounts are buzzing with excitement at the beauty and wealth of Kusko.
没错。所以他们都搬进了这些宫殿。当地人对此作何感想，我们不得而知。但他们没有反抗。你知道，他们没有起义。他们没有把西班牙人赶走。没有理由怀疑他们确实把西班牙人当作解放者来欢迎。西班牙人的记录中充满了对库斯科的美丽和财富的兴奋之情。
So Pedro Pizarro, Pedro Sancho, these accounts of the storehouses bursting with stuff, with cloaks, with gold, with weapons, with shields. All the goods that are manufactured in this country, says Pedro Sancho. You know, they can't believe the warehouse is full of stuff because there's no equivalent for this in Europe. The central government doesn't just pile up stuff in great warehouses and have it hanging around in its capital. And then, of course, the temples, they're the things they've really come for. So Cusco's temples were full of relics, ornaments, holy objects from other temples. Because basically, if the Inca's conquered you, they would demand some of your stuff as a sort of hostage for good behavior. And would this stuff be gold?
所以佩德罗·皮萨罗、佩德罗·桑乔，这些关于仓库里堆满东西的记载，有斗篷、黄金、武器、盾牌。佩德罗·桑乔说，这个国家制造的所有商品。你知道，他们无法相信仓库里装满了东西，因为在欧洲没有与之相当的东西。中央政府不会只是把东西堆在大仓库里，让它们闲置在首都。当然，还有寺庙，那才是他们真正想要的东西。所以库斯科的寺庙里装满了来自其他寺庙的圣物、装饰品和神圣物品。因为基本上，如果印加人征服了你，他们会要求你提供一些东西作为人质，以确保你表现良好。这些东西会是黄金吗？
Often it would be gold, of course, yes. It would be gold or silver. Of course, the thing they've really come to see is the Temple of the Sun, the Kodokansha, which is the thing we heard about right at the beginning. Now, the wall plates have already been taken. he uses Atta Elp's ransom, but the place is still absolutely stuffed with gold. So one of the conquistadors, Diego de Trujillo, wrote, As we entered, Vilak Umu, who was their high priest, cried, how dare you enter here?
当然，通常会是黄金，是的。会是黄金或白银。当然，他们真正想看的是太阳神庙，即科里坎查（Qorikancha），也就是我们在开头听到的那个。现在，墙上的金板已经被取走了。他使用了阿塔瓦尔帕的赎金，但那个地方仍然塞满了黄金。所以其中一位征服者，迭戈·德·特鲁希略写道，当我们进入时，他们的大祭司维拉克·乌穆哭喊道，你们怎么敢进入这里？
Anyone who enters here has to fast for a year beforehand and must enter barefoot and bearing a load. Which is true, this is what you had to do, is your kind of ritual thing. But we paid no attention to what he said and went in. I mean, presumably this is all through interpreters. I mean, it's interesting, isn't it, that a lot of the Spaniards, when they come to these temples, describe them as mosques. Because they're coming from the world of the Reconquista and the Conquista and the Conquist of Granada and stuff. Yeah, and so the kind of desoliation of mosques would be very much their bag. And so they go in. Another conquistador, Juan Ruiz de Athe, writes,
任何进入这里的人都必须提前禁食一年，并且必须赤脚并负重进入。这是真的，这就是你必须做的，这是一种仪式。但我们没有理会他说的话，直接进去了。我的意思是，大概这一切都是通过翻译进行的。我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？很多西班牙人在来到这些寺庙时，把它们描述为清真寺。因为他们来自收复失地运动、征服运动和格拉纳达征服等背景。是的，所以拆毁清真寺对他们来说是很平常的事。于是他们进去了。另一位征服者，胡安·鲁伊斯·德·阿尔塞写道，
Since Atso-Alpa had ordered that nothing of his fathers should be touched, we found many golden lamas, women, pictures, jars, and other objects. Are there any golden lamas left, or did they all get melted down? No, I don't think there are. See, I remember, you know, we were talking about the children's book last time, the children's books that had pictures of Atualpa's ransom. It was always golden llamas that were in the pictures for me, and sort of images of the sun and things. The two things that really are memorable from the temple.
由于阿塔瓦尔帕下令不得触碰他祖先的任何东西，我们发现了许多金羊驼、女人、画像、罐子和其他物品。还有金羊驼留下来吗，还是它们都被熔化了？不，我不认为还有。你看，我记得，你知道，我们上次谈到了儿童读物，那些有阿塔瓦尔帕赎金图片的儿童读物。对我来说，图片里总是有金羊驼，还有太阳之类的形象。这两样东西确实是寺庙里最令人难忘的。
So in the intro reading that you did, you mentioned a garden of the sun. This is from another chronicler, Thea Theta de Leon. In the rear of the cloisters was the garden of the sun. where all the flowers, fruits and leaves were of pure beaten gold. And we know they were because we know that they took one of them to Charles V's court to show him.
所以在你读的引言中，你提到了太阳花园。这是来自另一位编年史家，佩德罗·西耶萨·德·莱昂。在回廊的后面是太阳花园，那里所有的花、果实和叶子都是纯金打造的。我们知道它们是，因为我们知道他们把其中一个带到了查理五世的宫廷给他看。
And he said, wow, melt it down. They melted it down. They melted everything down. Because they did preserve the Aztec stuff, some of it. I mean, we do have Aztec treasures. That's a good question about why there's a difference. And I wonder if part of the difference,
他说，哇，把它熔了吧。他们把它熔了。他们把一切都熔了。因为他们确实保存了阿兹特克的物品，其中一些。我的意思是，我们确实有阿兹特克的宝藏。关于为什么会有这种差异，这是一个很好的问题。我想知道部分差异是否在于，
Charles V at this point is fighting. Remember we mentioned he's fighting two wars simultaneously. Yeah. And the demand for money, you know, fighting the French in Italy must just be overwhelming. No time for the arts. No time for the arts. The real star of the temple, there's a thing called the Pun Chow, which it means the dawn. And this was, and I quote, an image of the sun of great size made of gold, beautifully wrought and set with many precious stones.
查理五世此时正在打仗。记住我们提到的，他同时在打两场战争。是的。对金钱的需求，你知道，在意大利与法国人作战一定让人难以承受。没时间搞艺术。没时间搞艺术。寺庙里真正的明星，有一个叫“蓬乔”（Pun Chow）的东西，意思是黎明。这是一个，我引用一下，“一个巨大的太阳形象，由黄金制成，工艺精美，镶嵌着许多宝石。”
This image of the sun was the single most important of all Inca artifacts. And no one knows what happened to it. So there's one bass conquistador who basically went around for years afterwards saying, I lost it in a game of dice or something, very hand solo or whatever. That sounds improbable. Yeah, other people said that's rubbish. He never had it to lose. It just vanished and it was never found.
这个太阳形象是所有印加文物中最重要的一件。没人知道它发生了什么。所以有一个卑鄙的征服者，他在那之后多年里到处说，我在掷骰子游戏中把它输掉了之类的，非常像韩·索罗或者别的什么。这听起来不太可能。是的，其他人说那是胡说八道。他根本没得到过它，所以没法输掉。它只是消失了，再也没被找到。
So maybe it's still buried somewhere outside Kusko. That's the exciting thing in a cave or something. With the mummy of Atapalpa. With Atta Vapa's body, yeah, who knows? Now, while his men have been looking at all this golden stuff, Pizarre's been thinking about the future of the empire. The day after entering the city, he summons Manco and he says to him, you know, you're obviously a great chap.
所以也许它还埋在库斯科外面的某个地方。那才是令人兴奋的事情，在洞穴里或者什么地方。和阿塔瓦尔帕的木乃伊在一起。和阿塔瓦尔帕的尸体在一起，是的，谁知道呢？现在，当他的人在看所有这些金子的时候，皮萨罗一直在思考帝国的未来。进入城市后的第二天，他召见了曼科，他对他说，你知道，你显然是个了不起的人。
I want you to be the new emperor. So this is a fantastic moment for Manco. I mean, just a few months earlier, he was a teenage fugitive fearing for his life. And now he's going to become the Sapa Inca. He's going to get the whole thing. He goes off outside the city and he fasts for three days at a mountain retreat. And then he returns for his coronation, which is this absolutely massive public event. So he's going to be crowned with this kind of red tasseled string on his head. So the tassel
我希望你成为新皇帝。所以这对曼科来说是一个美妙的时刻。我的意思是，就在几个月前，他还是一个担心自己生命的少年逃犯。现在他要成为萨帕·印加了。他要得到这一切。他走到城外，在山中隐居处禁食了三天。然后他回来参加加冕典礼，这是一个绝对盛大的公共活动。所以他将戴上这种红色的流苏绳作为头饰。所以流苏
that goes down the forehead. Yes, exactly. There's loads of dancing. There's loads of fiestas and all this kind of stuff. Have they brought the mummies out? The mummies come out. Great. So Miguel de Estete, one of the conquistadors, has a lovely description and bringing out the mummies. They've all got diadems on their heads. They're put on thrones. There were women who ministered to them with as much respect as if they've been alive. And actually my favorite detail. So the mummies are brought out. And next to each mummy, there's a little kind of altar with Miguel de Estetti says on which were his fingernails, hair, teeth and other things that had been removed after death. I mean, imagine sitting next to Queen Victoria's teeth. Yeah, but what are the other things?
垂在额头上。是的，完全正确。有很多舞蹈。有很多节日和所有这类事情。他们把木乃伊带出来了吗？木乃伊出来了。太棒了。所以米格尔·德·埃斯特特，其中一位征服者，对带出木乃伊有很可爱的描述。他们头上都戴着王冠。他们被放在宝座上。有妇女像对待活人一样恭敬地侍奉他们。实际上我最喜欢的细节是。所以木乃伊被带出来了。在每个木乃伊旁边，都有一个小祭坛，米格尔·德·埃斯特特说，上面放着死后被移除的指甲、头发、牙齿和其他东西。我的意思是，想象一下坐在维多利亚女王的牙齿旁边。是的，但其他东西是什么？
Finger nails, hair, teeth. What does that leave? What else? What are the other things? And then here's the fun detail. And I quote, I think this is from Miguel de Estetre again, there were so many people in the past. in the parties and both men and women
指甲、头发、牙齿。那还剩下什么？还有什么？其他东西是什么？然后这里有一个有趣的细节。我引用一下，我想这又是来自米格尔·德·埃斯特特，过去有很多人。在聚会中，男人和女人
were such heavy drinkers that all day two wide drains ran with urine as abundantly as a flowing spring gorgeous so just imagine the scene
都是酒鬼，以至于整天两条宽大的排水沟里流淌着尿液，就像流动的泉水一样，太美了，所以想象一下那个场景。
you're there as a Spaniard the sight of mummies being paraded around with their fingernails teeth and other things and meanwhile people are constantly relieving themselves
你作为西班牙人在那里，看到木乃伊带着它们的指甲、牙齿和其他东西被游行展示，与此同时人们不断地在
into these massive overflowing drains of urine so it's that being in a festival I guess Yeah, it's kind of Glastonbury, isn't it? Or the Rest is History Festival at Hampton Court this summer. I don't think that the people who will be coming to our wonderful festival would be urinating and bringing the mummies of their ancestors.
这些巨大的、溢出的尿液排水沟里排泄，所以这就是参加节日的感觉，我想。是的，这有点像格拉斯顿伯里音乐节，不是吗？或者今年夏天在汉普顿宫举行的“历史的其余部分”艺术节。我不认为那些会来参加我们精彩艺术节的人会一边小便一边带着他们祖先的木乃伊。
I mean, I may be surprised. Who knows? Yeah. But I don't think so. I put nothing past the members of the Restis History Club, quite frankly. So the climax to this event is the Spanish you take charge. Vicente de Valverde reads Mass, and then they parade into the square where Manco is sitting on a stool surrounded by his nobles.
我的意思是，我可能会感到惊讶。谁知道呢？是的。但我不这么认为。坦率地说，我对“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员不抱任何期望。所以这个活动的高潮是西班牙人接管。文森特·德·瓦尔韦德举行弥撒，然后他们游行进入广场，曼科坐在凳子上，周围是他的贵族。
And then Pizarro's secretary Pedro Sancho reads out for all to hear the requirement, which we've discussed earlier. It's this mad legal thing that the Spanish have to read, the history of the world, the story of Christ,
然后皮萨罗的秘书佩德罗·桑乔大声读出我们之前讨论过的“要求书”。这是西班牙人必须阅读的疯狂法律文件，世界历史，基督的故事，
the history of the papacy and the, it's like a brilliant, Restis History series, and the Spanish monarchy and then the legal obligation of the Inca's to accept the Pope, the church, and the king of Spain.
教皇的历史，这就像一个精彩的“历史的其余部分”系列，以及西班牙君主制，然后是印加人接受教皇、教会和西班牙国王的法律义务。
And then it ends, with this warning, which always amuses me. If they don't do this, the Spanish are legally obliged to do you, quote, all the harm and damage that we can, and any deaths and losses which shall result from this are your fault. So it's like those little disclaimers that we read at the end of our Restors History adverts. Exactly. May contain. Side effects may include.
然后它以这个警告结束，这总是让我觉得很有趣。如果他们不这样做，西班牙人在法律上有义务对你们做，引用，“我们能做的所有伤害和破坏，由此产生的任何死亡和损失都是你们的错。”所以这就像我们在“历史的其余部分”广告结尾读到的那些小免责声明。完全正确。可能包含。副作用可能包括。
So at the end, Manco and Pizarro share a kind of golden cup. There's a ritual where all his chiefs pay tribute to the flag of Spain. The Inca sing a lovely song, thanking the sun for allowing them to drive out their enemies, and thanking the son for sending the Spanish to rule over them. Miguel de Estete says in his memoir, I do not believe they truly meant it. They only wanted to make us think they were happy with our company. I don't think you have to be terribly astute to draw that conclusion.
最后，曼科和皮萨罗分享了一个金杯。有一个仪式，他所有的酋长都向西班牙国旗致敬。印加人唱了一首可爱的歌，感谢太阳让他们赶走了敌人，并感谢太阳派遣西班牙人来统治他们。米格尔·德·埃斯特特在他的回忆录中说，我不相信他们是真心的。他们只是想让我们以为他们对我们的陪伴感到高兴。我认为你不必非常精明就能得出这个结论。
And then one more set piece. Sometimes people, perhaps the more earnest listeners to this podcast, sometimes comment, there's a lot of bad behavior towards. animals at the rest is history. And this is a very good example. Because Manco decides to celebrate his triumph with a traditional royal hunt, which is called a Chaco. And he sends out 10,000 beaters, 10,000 beaters,
然后是另一个固定节目。有时人们，也许是这个播客更认真的听众，有时会评论说，在“历史的其余部分”中有很多对待动物的恶劣行为。这是一个很好的例子。因为曼科决定用传统的皇家狩猎来庆祝他的胜利，这被称为“查科”（Chaco）。他派出了10,000名驱赶者，10,000名驱赶者，
to encircle this huge area of the countryside around Kusko. And these blokes basically have to sort of close ranks slowly until they can all hold hands. And inside this huge ring of people are now trapped all the animals. So that's Vicunias and Guilla's. Manacos, which are kind of bit like llamas. There's roe deer, mountain foxes, hares and pumas. And then Manco and his entourage enter the ring, along with Pizarro, and about 50 Spaniards
去包围库斯科周围这片巨大的乡村区域。这些家伙基本上必须慢慢地靠拢，直到他们都能手拉手。在这个巨大的人圈里，现在困住了所有的动物。所以那是小羊驼和原驼。马纳科（Manacos），有点像羊驼。有狍子、山狐、野兔和美洲狮。然后曼科和他的随从进入圈内，连同皮萨罗和大约50名西班牙人，
who've all been armed with sticks. And then they have a brilliant time killing every animal in sight, bludgeoning them to death. They're not tossing them. Not tossing them. And the sources say they killed 11,000 animals with sticks. God, I wouldn't want to take on a puma with a stick. No, you wouldn't. In fact, I wouldn't want to take any orphan with a stick.
他们都拿着棍子。然后他们度过了一段美好的时光，杀死了视线内的每一只动物，用棍子把它们打死。他们不是在扔它们。不是在扔它们。资料说他们用棍子杀死了11,000只动物。天哪，我可不想用棍子去对付一只美洲狮。不，你不会的。事实上，我不想用棍子去对付任何孤儿。
No, no, I think that's fair. John Heming says on the plus side, it was a moment of great cordiality between Spaniards and Peruvians. It's the universal language, isn't it? Killing animals. Yeah, but bad news, Tom, this cordiality is not going to last. Because beyond the gates of Kusko, Kis is still there with his northern army. And further north, there is an army under a much more terrifying warlord who has just turned one of his victims into a musical instrument. Tom, a very different hunt will soon begin.
不，不，我认为这很公平。约翰·赫明说，从好的方面来看，这是西班牙人和秘鲁人之间非常亲切的时刻。这是通用语言，不是吗？杀害动物。是的，但坏消息，汤姆，这种亲切感不会持续太久。因为在库斯科城门之外，基斯基斯（Kiskis）仍然带着他的北方军队在那里。而在更北边，有一支军队由一个更可怕的军阀领导，他刚刚把他的一个受害者变成了乐器。汤姆，一场非常不同的狩猎很快就要开始了。
But this time, who is the hunter and who is the hunted? Well, we will find out after the break and we will be meeting the human drum. They go away. This episode is brought to you by Claude, by Anthropic. Now, history lives in the contradictions. Yeah, I've always been fascinated by the great mysteries of history. Like what happened to the Maya civilization of Central America? Why were all those great cities deserted?
但这一次，谁是猎人，谁是猎物？好吧，我们将在休息后找出答案，我们将见到那个人体鼓。他们走开了。本集由Anthropic的Claude赞助。现在，历史存在于矛盾之中。是的，我一直对历史上的伟大谜团着迷。比如中美洲的玛雅文明发生了什么？为什么那些伟大的城市被遗弃了？
But Tom, there's one mystery that's always fascinated you, isn't there? Yes, Dominic, I've always been fascinated by the question of how humans came to make and use fire. How did that originate? And a tremendous discovery was announced just last year that the place where it seems fire was invented was Suffolk. Well, you know, one of the things that makes history so fascinating is the kind of back and forth between sources to try and explain these great mysteries. And you know what's built for that kind of thinking? Claude is built for that way of thinking.
但汤姆，有一个谜团一直让你着迷，不是吗？是的，多米尼克，我一直对人类是如何制造和使用火的问题着迷。它是如何起源的？去年宣布了一个惊人的发现，火似乎是在萨福克发明的。好吧，你知道，让历史如此迷人的事情之一就是来源之间的来回推敲，试图解释这些伟大的谜团。你知道什么适合那种思考方式吗？Claude就是为那种思考方式而构建的。
It doesn't smooth things over. It helps you dig into the disagreement to reveal something new. Anthropic just committed to not running adverts in Claude. So your thinking stays yours. Try Claude for free at clod. Hello, welcome back to The Restless History. It is January 1534. We're in Cusco, the capital of the Inca's.
它不会掩盖问题。它帮助你深入挖掘分歧，揭示一些新的东西。Anthropic刚刚承诺不在Claude中投放广告。所以你的思考仍然是你自己的。在clod免费试用Claude。你好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”。现在是1534年1月。我们在印加帝国的首都库斯科。
And it's only three years since Francisco Pizarro set off from Panama. It's a year since he captured Atahelpa. And so far, Dominic, it has to be said, I mean, he has enjoyed an incredible streak of luck. So many points where things could have gone. slightly differently, and he and all the Spaniards would have been wiped out. But instead, here he is. He's installed in the great capital of the Inca's, you know, the very center of this massive empire. He's got temples.
距离弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗从巴拿马出发才过去三年。距离他俘虏阿塔瓦尔帕才过去一年。到目前为止，多米尼克，必须说，我的意思是，他享受了一连串令人难以置信的好运。有太多次事情可能会有稍微不同的走向，他和所有的西班牙人都会被消灭。但相反，他在这里。他入驻了印加人的伟大首都，你知道，这个庞大帝国的中心。他有寺庙。
He's got palaces all around him. They've got this compliant young puppet in the form of Manco. He must just be thinking, this is great. Everything's going superbly. What could possibly go wrong? Yeah, you're absolutely right. And now he can really get stuck into what he's come here for, which is the gold. So some of the gold of Kusko has been moved north to Kiamaka, but not all of it.
他周围有宫殿。他们有曼科这个顺从的年轻傀儡。他一定在想，这太棒了。一切都进行得非常顺利。可能会出什么问题呢？是的，你说得完全对。现在他可以真正投入到他来这里的目的，也就是黄金。所以库斯科的一些黄金已经被转移到北部的卡哈马卡，但不是全部。
There is a lot more gold in the temples of Kusko, and there is four times as much silver as the Spanish have already shared out. So for the Spanish, this is basically the best thing ever. So all their accounts, you know, they say, you know, wherever you went, you basically found pictures of gold, gold and effigies. Pedro Pizarro has a section where he says, you know, we went and found to this. cave and it was full of women's shoes made of gold. I mean, you can see why it drives the Spaniards mad, because this is exactly what in their wildest fantasies they had been imagining. And now those fantasies have come true. And it will implant a kind of gold lust that will continue to rage for decades and centuries afterwards. Yeah, it will. And actually, the mad thing that they're
库斯科的寺庙里还有更多的黄金，白银的数量是西班牙人已经分掉的四倍。所以对西班牙人来说，这基本上是最好的事情。所以他们所有的记载，你知道，他们说，无论你走到哪里，你基本上都能找到黄金画像、黄金雕像。佩德罗·皮萨罗有一节说，你知道，我们去找到了这个洞穴，里面装满了金做的女鞋。我的意思是，你可以看出为什么这让西班牙人发疯，因为这正是他们最狂野的幻想中所想象的。现在这些幻想成真了。它将植入一种贪婪，这种贪婪将在随后的几十年和几个世纪里持续肆虐。是的，它会。实际上，关于他们所有人闹翻的疯狂事情，他们确实闹翻了，剧透警告，他们最终都互相残杀，是他们都是非常有钱的人。他们现在有足够的钱在西班牙买下国家的庄园，建立家族声誉，所有这些事情。但对更多东西的贪婪似乎抓住了他们。还有竞争心，以及担心你的黄金会被夺走的恐惧，我想。
about them all falling out, which they do, spoiler alerts, they all end up killing each other, is they were all really rich men. They've got enough money now to buy a country of states back in Spain, to make their family's reputation, all of this kind of thing. But the lust for more and more just seems to seize them. And the competitiveness, and the fear that your gold will be taken away, I suppose.
那一直都在他们的脑海里。有一个叫克里斯托弗的道德家。有一个叫克里斯托弗的道德家。所以有一个年轻的牧师写了一份关于此的记录，克里斯托瓦尔·德·莫利纳。他们唯一的关心就是收集黄金和白银，让自己都变得富有，而不去想他们所做的是错误的，他们正在破坏和摧毁。因为被摧毁的东西比他们拥有的任何东西都更完美。
That's at the back of their mind the whole time. There is Christopher a moralist. There is Christopher a moralist. So there's a young priest who wrote an account of this, Christobald de Molina. Their only concern was to collect gold and silver to make themselves all rich without thinking that what they were doing was wrong and that they were wrecking and destroying. For what was being destroyed was more perfect than anything they possessed.
所以这就像对特诺奇蒂特兰之美的哀叹，不是吗？是的，在那被摧毁之后。当时显然有人认为，你知道，有一两个人认为，天哪，等等，我们在这里失去理智了吗？我们是坏人吗？我们是坏人，完全正确。但皮萨罗本人没有心情胡闹。所以在他进入城市一个月后的1533年12月15日，
So it's like the lamentations over the beauties of Tenor Titlan, isn't it? Yeah, after that had been destroyed. And there are people clearly at the time who think, you know, there are one or two people to think, God, hold on, are we losing our minds here? Are we the baddies here? Are we the baddies, exactly. But Pizarro himself is in no mood to mess around. So exactly one month after he entered the city on the 15th of December, 1533,
他说让我们开始熔化吧。在接下来的两个月里，就像在卡哈马卡一样，熔炉日夜轰鸣，他们又生产了另一批巨大的、巨大的金银条，准备运回西班牙。现在，与此同时，皮萨罗正在考虑更广泛的印加帝国的问题。所以皮萨罗不是傻瓜。他知道科尔特斯在墨西哥发生了什么，
he says let's start the melting down. And for the next two months, as in Cajomaca, the forges are roaring day and night and they're producing another colossal, colossal horde of gold and silver bars for shipment back to Spain. Now, in the meantime, Pizarro is thinking about the issue of the wider Inca Empire. So Pizarro is not a fool. He knows what happened to Cortez in Mexico,
科尔特斯最终被困在阿兹特克首都特诺奇蒂特兰，即未来的墨西哥城，基本上不得不杀出一条血路。他不想让这种情况发生在他身上。所以如果我们考虑地图，把印加帝国分成三部分，因为它很长，它不宽，它只是非常长。西班牙人在中间的三分之一。所以那基本上是现代的秘鲁。
that Cortez ended up cornered in the Aztec capital, Tenostitland, the future Mexico city, and basically had to fight his way out. And he doesn't want that to happen to him. So if we think about the map and think about the Inca Empire in thirds, because it's a long, it's not wide, it's just very long. The Spaniards are in the central third. So that's basically modern-day Peru.
他们控制着皮萨罗和曼科。然后你有下面的南部三分之一。那是现代的玻利维亚和智利北部。到目前为止，还没有西班牙人去过那里。他们不知道那里是什么样。但据他们所知，它对曼科是忠诚的。所以那没问题。但问题是北部三分之一。
And they control that Pizarro and Manco. Then you've got the southern third to below that. And that's modern day Bolivia and northern Chile. And that's so far, no Spaniard has been there. They don't know what it's like. But as far as they know, it's loyal to Manco. So that's fine. But the problem is the northern third.
所以那是现代的厄瓜多尔和哥伦比亚南部。那是阿塔瓦尔帕的心脏地带。你知道，北方人民心中的内战仍在继续。而西班牙人只是这场战争中的一个新因素。阿塔瓦尔帕在监禁期间的成就之一就是让基多和北方免受西班牙人的关注，不是吗？他把所有的掠夺小队都派往南方了。
So that's modern day Ecuador and southern Colombia. That is Attawalpa's heartland. You know, the civil war in the minds of the people of the north is still going on. and the Spaniards are merely a new factor in this war. And one of Atta Huolper's achievements during his imprisonment had been to spare Quito and the north from the attentions of the Spaniards, hasn't it? He'd sent all the kind of the looting party southwards.
是的，完全正确。所以如果西班牙人想在曼科的领导下统一帝国，他们将不得不击败阿塔瓦尔帕的前将军们，其中两个，我的意思是，他们已经烧死了查尔科·查尔奇马，但其中两个还在逃。所以其中一个是这个家伙，基斯基斯（Kiskis），他之前在库斯科。他被从库斯科赶到了北方。
Yes, exactly. So if the Spaniards want to unite the empire under Manco, they will have to beat Atowelper's former generals, two of whom, I mean, they've already burned Chalko Chalchima, but two of them are on the loose. So one of them is this guy, Kiskees, who had previously been in Kusko. He's been driven north from Kusko.
他可能还有大约20,000人，所以此时是相当久经沙场的部队。基斯基斯的大多数人，虽然他们久经沙场，但他们精疲力竭。他们在路上走了，什么，两年了，他们想回家去厄瓜多尔，所以他一直带着一大群人蹒跚地走回厄瓜多尔。
He still probably has about 20,000 men, so quite battle-hardened troops at this point. Most of Kiskis' men, although they're battle-hardened, they are exhausted. They've been on the road for, what, two years, and they want to go home to Ecuador, and so he's trudging back all this time towards Ecuador with a gigantic mob.
我的意思是，成千上万的羊驼和搬运工带着他们所有的东西。所以记住他们。但在北方还有另一位将军，他是一个非常无情的人。这就是一个叫鲁米尼亚维（Ruminjawi）的家伙。他带着一些非常丰富多彩的行为进入了这个故事，我们已经广泛地预告过了。所以基本上，在阿塔瓦尔帕死后，
I mean, thousands of lamas and porters carrying all their stuff. So bear them in mind. But there is another general up in the north who is a very ruthless man. And this is a guy called Ruminjawi. And he enters this story with some very colourful behaviour, which we have been trailing extensively. So basically, after Attau'alpa died,
北方人之间有一个关于谁将接替他作为继承人的问题。阿塔瓦尔帕有一个兄弟叫基利·斯卡特查（Kili Skatecha）。他说，好吧，我来做。目前还不清楚他是想自己当皇帝，还是为阿塔瓦尔帕的儿子们当摄政王。总之，鲁米尼亚维，他是指挥官，军事指挥官，他说，你想做吗？
there was a question among the northerners about who would succeed him as the claimant. Atowalpa had a brother called Kili Skatecha. And he said, well, I'll do it. And it's not clear whether he wants to be emperor himself, regent for Attawalpa's sons. Anyway, Ruminjawi, who was the commander, the military commander, he said, you want to do it?
太棒了。让我们为阿塔瓦尔帕举行一场盛大的守灵仪式。你知道，我们将举办一个派对来庆祝并庆祝你的晋升。他们举行了这次守灵仪式。这就像某种红色婚礼之类的。鲁米尼亚维给基利卡和他的随从。他说，喝点可爱的饮料。这些饮料被下了药。当他们昏倒时，
Great. Let's have a big wake for Atalpa. You know, we'll have a party to celebrate and celebrate your elevation. They have this wake. It's like the sort of red wedding or something. Ruminiawi gives Kiliqa and his entourage. He says, have some lovely drinks. These drinks have been drugged. And when they pass out,
鲁米尼亚维的人割断了他们的喉咙。所以这就是他们的结局。嗯，不完全是结局，因为鲁米尼亚维随后真的把基利·斯卡特查变成了一个鼓，我引用一下，我不应该笑，因为它很可怕。
Rumi Nawis men cut their throats. So that's the end of them. well, not quite the end, because then Rumi Niawi literally turns Kilius Kachar into a drum and I quote, I shouldn't laugh because it's hideous.
他通过某个部位取出了所有的骨头。我们不知道那个部位是什么。这些编年史家很害羞，不是吗？是的，他通过某个部位取出了所有的骨头，保持皮肤完整，把他做成了一个鼓。肩膀形成了鼓的一端，
He extracted all the bones through a certain part. We don't know what that part is. Very coy these chroniclers, aren't they? Yeah, he extracted all the bones through a certain part, leaving the skin intact and made him into a drum. The shoulders formed one end of the
腹部是另一端。所以，头、脚和手被防腐处理，他被完整地保存下来，但被转化了……他被完整地保存下来，但被转化成了一个定音鼓。天哪。好吧，你知道，这就像扬·杰式卡，胡斯派将军，但他死后让人把自己做成了鼓。是吗？
drum and the abdomen the other. So, with the head, feet and hands embalmed, he was preserved intact but transformed... He was preserved intact but transformed into a kettle drum. Goodness. Well, you know, it's like Jan Zizka, the Hussite General, but he had himself turned into a drum after he died. Did he?
故事是这么说的。你看，鲁米尼亚维有这个家伙做鼓，但他们甚至不是特别……敌人。他只是一个被背后捅了一刀的前盟友。我的意思是，这对其他人来说是一个很好的教训，不是吗？你不要惹他。有了这个定音鼓，他现在作为独立的军阀统治基多。我的意思是，他实际上是北方的国王，鲁米尼亚维。然而，他的问题是现在西班牙人在追捕他。所以西班牙人听到了传言，说基多和库斯科一样富有，他们想要它的黄金。多米尼克，还有其他人听到了类似的传言吗，
So the story goes. See, Rumi Nyawi's got this bloke as a drum, but they weren't even particularly... enemies. He's just a former ally who was stabbed in the back. I mean, it's a good lesson to others, isn't it? You don't mess with him. So with this kettle drum, he now rules in Quito as an independent warlord. I mean, he's literally kind of the king in the north, Rumi Nyawi. His problem, however, is now the Spanish are after him. So the Spanish have heard rumors that Quito is just as rich as Kuzko, and they want its gold. Dominic, is there someone else who has heard similar rumors,
我们在之前的系列中见过他？我们在“历史的其余部分”中做过的最好的人之一。他和奥古斯都大帝、凯撒以及所有其他有污点历史的节目大朋友们并列。他是一个热爱吉尔（Gile）的人。他喜欢大笑。他喜欢在节日里屠杀土著人民。他喜欢和女孩们去康沃尔、罗克或类似的地方度周末。
who we have met in a previous series? One of the best people we've ever done on the rest of his history. He's up there with Augustus the Strong, the Kaiser, and all the other big friends of the show with checkered pasts. He is a man who loves a Gile. He loves a great laugh. He loves a massacre of indigenous people at a festival. And he loves a weekend trip with the girls to Cornwall, to rock or similar.
他爬上了塞维利亚的吉拉尔达塔。他在墨西哥表现得很糟糕。他几乎肯定去了塔比的母校，莫尔伯勒学院。他是佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多。所以他一直在做什么？所以如果你听了“美国的衰落”，你会记得佩德罗·阿尔瓦拉多是一个很有趣的人，但你想和他保持良好的关系。
He climbed the Giralda in Seville. He let himself down quite badly in Mexico. He almost certainly went to Tabby's old school, Moorborough College. he's Pedro de Alvarado. So what's he been doing? So if you listen to the fall of the United States, you will remember that Pedro Alvarado is a great laugh, but you want to stay on the right side of him.
所以实际上，他一直在危地马拉到处狂欢，他一直在屠杀土著人民，成为一个彻头彻尾的传奇。他听到了所有关于秘鲁黄金的传言，他想加入。所以他终于出现了。1534年2月，佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多带着一大批西班牙步兵和弩手，500人，在厄瓜多尔海岸登陆。
So actually, he's been roistering around Guatemala, and he's been slaughtering indigenous people and being a total legend. And he's heard all these rumors of the gold of Peru, and he wants in. So he finally turns up. February 1534, Pedro de Alvarado lands on the coast of Ecuador, with a load of Spanish infantry and crossbowmen, 500 of them.
所以他带着很多人和4,000名危地马拉人出现了。佩德罗的一件伟大的事情是，他触碰的一切都变成了灰尘和灾难。即使在他到达时，中美洲的人们也在写信给西班牙说，佩德罗出现了，对他来说一切都会变得非常糟糕。所以巴拿马的一位官员写信给查理五世，虽然有很多危地马拉人，但我相信他们很快都会死，因为他们来自炎热的国家，要去一个寒冷的国家。这听起来巴拿马的官员是个白痴，但没有，他实际上是对的。
So he's turned up with a lot of men and 4,000 Guatemalans. And a great thing about Pedro is everything he touches turns to dust and disaster. Even as he arrives, people in Central America are writing to Spain saying, Pedro's turned up and it's all going to go horribly wrong for him. So an official in Panama writes to Charles V, although there are many Guatemalans, I believe they will all die soon because they're from a hot country and they're going to a cold one. And that sounds like the official in Panama is an idiot, but no, he's actually quite right.
所以阿尔瓦拉多以绝对教科书式的佩德罗风格开始了。他沉溺于约翰·赫明所说的对沿海部落的一些不必要的残忍。哦，别那样做，佩德罗。哦，佩德罗，别那样做。哦，佩德罗。佩德罗真是个笑话。所以即使按照西班牙的标准，他也是如此残忍，以至于其他征服者后来举行了司法调查。
So Alvarado kicks off in absolutely textbook Pedro fashion. He indulges in what John Heming calls some unnecessary cruelty to the coastal tribes. Oh, don't do that, Pedro. Oh, Pedro, don't do that. Oh, Pedro. Pedro's such a laugh. So even by Spanish standards, he is so cruel that the other conquistadors later hold a Judicial inquiry.
我的意思是，你得有多坏？是的，对于所有其他人，皮萨罗，所有这些人说你越界了。所以给你一个指示，他开始奴役妇女和儿童，链条帮，他绞死了一些村长，他让人活活烧死，他让人把一个当地酋长喂给狗吃。因为他买了一大堆战犬，不是吗？是的，他买了。他买了。我喜欢狗。猎犬。
I mean, how bad do you have to be? Yeah, for all the other guys, Pizarro, all these people saying you've crossed the line. So to give you an indication, he starts enslaving women and children, slit chain gangs, he hangs some village chiefs, he has people burned alive, he has one local chief fed to some dogs. Because he's bought a whole load of war dogs, hasn't he? Yes, he has. He has. I love a dog. A hoon.
然后一旦他在那里玩得开心，他就带着数百名被奴役的当地人作为搬运工，向森林深处的基多进发。大剧透警告，这对搬运工或者任何与佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多的探险队有关的人来说都不会有好结果。而其他西班牙人，其他征服者领袖，当阿尔瓦拉多出现时，那是一场血腥的屠杀，对吧？是的。我的意思是，你有点会说，哦不。是的，他们被掏空了。不是阿尔瓦拉多。那有点不可靠。
And then once he's had some fun there, he heads inland into the forest towards Quito, having enslaved hundreds of local people to act as his porters. Big spoiler alert, this is not going to end well for the porters or indeed for anybody else associated with Pedro de Alvarado's expedition. And the other Spaniards, the other conquistador leaders, when Alvarado turns up, it's a bloody massacre, right? Yeah. I mean, you kind of go, oh no. Yeah, they're gutted. Not Alvarado. That is a little bit unreliable.
他们会血流成河。完全正确。他们被掏空了。实际上，他们很震惊。两支竞争对手的军队立即出发。我的意思是，我说是军队，它们是某种探险队，试图在阿尔瓦拉多之前抢到基多的黄金。所以其中一支从海岸出发，是皮萨罗的一位队长手下的200人，一个叫塞巴斯蒂安·德·贝纳尔卡萨尔（Sebastian de Benalcazar）的家伙，他来自安达卢西亚，编年史家。编年史家佩德罗·西耶萨·德·莱昂说他是一个知识贫乏、出身卑微、智力低下的人。
They're going to be bloody carnage. Exactly. They're gutted. They're shocked, actually. And immediately two other rival armies shoot off. I mean, I say armies, they're sort of expeditions, to try to beat Alvarado to the gold of Quito. So one of them goes from the coast, and it's 200 men under one of Pizarro's captains, a guy called Sebastian de Ben Al-Katha, who is from Andaluthea, the Chronocl. The chronicler Theaethe de Leon said he was a man of little knowledge, poor origin and a low intellect.
这并没有真正激发信心。是的，但实际上他做得很好，正如我们将要看到的。另一个是阿尔马格罗，皮萨罗的合伙人。想象一下如果你是阿尔马格罗，对吧？你已经被骗走了一大堆黄金。现在你认为，好吧，至少我可能会得到基多的黄金。现在阿尔瓦拉多带着他的红裤子出现了，要抢你的女朋友。哦，亲爱的。
Which doesn't really inspire confidence. Yeah, but actually he does quite well as we shall see. And the other is Al-Magro, Pizarro's partner. Imagine if you're Al-Magro, right? You've already been treated out of a load of gold once. Now you think, well, at least I'll probably get the gold of keto. And now Alvarado has turned up with his red trousers to get your girlfriends. Oh, dear.
你就像，哦，不。所以接下来发生的事情是一个疯狂的故事。它非常，我已经提到了“权力的游戏”。它非常乔治·R·R·马丁。实际上，西班牙编年史家没有详细记录它是一种耻辱。所以，你知道，细节有点粗略。贝纳尔卡萨尔先到了那里。他穿过秘鲁北部的沙漠。
You're like, oh, no. So what happens next is a bonkers story. It's very, I already mentioned Game of Thrones. It's very George Arar Martin. It's actually a shame that the Spanish chroniclers don't go into it in loads of detail. So, you know, the details are a bit sketchy. Ben Alcathara gets there first. He goes across the desert of northern Peru.
他走进山里，出现在厄瓜多尔南部的高沼地上。他带了一大批叫卡尼亚里（Canyari）的当地支持者。卡尼亚里人一直讨厌印加人。阿塔瓦尔帕对他们非常残忍。他们基本上迫不及待地想在基多大干一场。他们无法忍受基多。那个混蛋怎么样？他们的混蛋现在增加了画面，汤姆。
He goes up into the mountains and he comes out on the high moors of southern Ecuador. And he's picked up a load of native supporters called the canyari. The canyari had always hated the Inca's. Atowalpa had been really cruel to them. They basically can't wait to have a crack at Keto. They can't stand Keto. What about the wanker? Their wanker adds to the picture now, Tom.
他们不是其中的一部分。不，他们不是其中的一部分。所以他们向基多推进，他们到达了钦博拉索山（Mount Chimborathol）的阴影下。那真是个奇幻故事，不是吗？在山影下的特奥卡斯（Teokahas）小村庄，这个叫鲁米尼亚维的家伙正在等他们。带着他的鼓。带着他的大鼓和他的庞大军队。
They're not part of it. No, they're not part of it. So they advanced towards Keto, and they get to the shadow of Mount Chimborathol. That is so fantasy story, isn't it? And at the hamlet of Teokahas in the shadow of this mountain, this bloke Ruminiawi is waiting for them. With his drum. With his huge drum and his massive army.
你知道，我想阿尔瓦拉多会，我的意思是，他会觉得那是一个非常好的笑话。带着鼓。是的。是的，他会把很多人变成鼓，他会有一个古老的管弦乐队。带着长号。你能把某人变成什么最有趣的乐器？双簧管。如果他们说，你最终会变成一个三角铁，你会感到被掏空。
Do you know, I reckon that Alvarado would, I mean, he'd find that a bloody good laugh. With a drum. Yeah. Yeah, he'd turn loads of people and he'd have an old orchestra of people. With trombones. What would the most amusing instruments that you could make somebody into? An oba. You'd be gutted if they said, you're going to end up as a triangle.
是的，你真的会。总之，这场战斗，对吧？我的意思是，历史学家，首先，他们不能同意它是什么时候发生的，可能是1534年5月。他们甚至不能同意叫它什么。所以一些历史学家称它为特奥卡斯战役。有些人称它为钦博拉索山战役。他们不能同意。
Yeah, you really would. Anyway, this battle, right? I mean, historians, first of all, they can't agree when it happened, possibly third of men. May, 1534. They don't even agree what to call it. So some historians call it the Battle of Teukhas. Some people call it the Battle of Mount Chimbaratho. They can't agree.
这是一场没人知道任何事情的巨大战斗。所以西班牙编年史家贡萨洛·费尔南德斯·德·奥维耶多声称那里有50,000人在战斗。其中十分之九是土著。西班牙人只是这场战斗的一小部分。但西班牙人，因为它是在高沼地上，这有利于西班牙马匹。奥维耶多的记录实际上很棒。
It's a massive battle that no one knows anything about. So the Spanish chronicler, Gonzalo Fernandez de Obiedo, claimed that there were 50,000 people fighting there. Nine out of ten of them were indigenous. The Spanish are only a tiny element of this battle. But the Spanish, because it's on the high moors, that favours the Spanish horses. And Oviedo's account is great actually.
他说它开始于这种指环王式的，帕兰诺平原战役，西班牙骑兵冲锋。他们在大喊“圣地亚哥”。我引用一下，“他们猛烈地攻击，把印第安人踩在马下，用长矛造成了巨大的流血。这一方表现出了可怕的勇敢和愤怒。印第安人聚集在一起，高喊这是为自由而战的时刻。”
He says it started with this sort of Lord the Rings, Battle of the Pelano Fields charged by the Spanish cavalry. They were shouting Santiago. And I quote, they attacked fiercely, trampling the Indians under their horses and causing great bloodshed with their lances. Terrible bravery and fury were shown by the side. The Indians rallied to a cry that this was the moment of fight for their liberty.
西班牙人喊道他们是。他们的生命危在旦夕。印第安人的勇敢是杰出的，尽管他们看到战场浸透了鲜血，覆盖着死者的尸体，尽管他们意识到自己的厄运，但他们仍然以惊人的活力战斗，既不缺乏力量也不缺乏精神。
The Spaniards shouted that they were. Their very lives were at stake. The Indians' bravery was exceptional, although they saw the battlefield soaked in blood and covered with the bodies of their dead, and although they realized their doom, they fought on with marvellous vigor, lacking neither strength nor spirit.
所以这是一场伟大的托尔金式的冲突。鲁米尼亚维的人有崩溃的危险，但随后他们重整旗鼓，他们杀死了一些马匹，也许他们确实设法用棍子把它们打死，或者用鼓打它们什么的。他们迫使西班牙人撤退，夜幕降临，双方陷入僵局。
So it's this great sort of Tolkien-esque clash. And Rumiño's men were in danger breaking, but then they rallied, they killed some of the horses, maybe they did manage to club them to death, or hit them with a drum or whatever. and they forced the Spanish to fall back and night falls and the two sides are deadlocked
你会认为这对西班牙人来说可能是一场灾难，因为他们人数处于劣势，但一夜之间，西班牙人欺骗了基多人，他们留下了营火，但在黑暗中溜走了，鲁米尼亚维的人直到太晚才意识到，他们只是把搬运工留在了后面吗？我想他们一定留下了一些，我猜。
and you would think this might be a disaster for the Spanish since they're outnumbered but overnight the Spanish tricks the Keitans they left their campfires burning but they slipped away in the darkness and Ruminawa's men didn't realise till it was too late and did they just leave their porters and behind I think they must have left some of them I guess
但这意味着他们基本上能够进入基多。所以贝纳尔卡萨尔和他的手下基本上能够绕过鲁米尼亚维的军队进入基多。但当他们到达那里时，他们很失望地发现鲁米尼亚维已经采取了某种俄罗斯1812年风格的行动。鲁米尼亚维掏空了基多。他带走了所有的宝藏。他带走了阿塔瓦尔帕的家人。他带走了4,000名妇女。
but what this means that basically they're able to get into Quito So Ben Alcatha and his men are able to basically skirt Rumiñois' army and get into Quito. But when they get there, they're gutted to find that Ruminiawi has already taken sort of Russia 1812 style action. Ruminioi has gutted Quito. He'd taken all the treasure. He's taken Atowalpa's family. He's taken 4,000 women.
他放火烧了宫殿和仓库。他撤退了。他基本上带着所有这些人撤退了。进入森林。鲁米尼亚维的一些糟糕行为。鲁米尼亚维和他的手下对太阳神庙的处女说，她们有300人。你们应该和我们一起离开，因为西班牙人会到达，
And he's set fire to the palaces and the storehouses. And he's withdrawn. And he's basically withdrawn with all them. into the forests. Some poor behaviour by Ruminari. Ruminio and his men said to the virgins of the sun temple, there were 300 of them. You should leave with us because the Spanish will arrive
如果你不走，他们会强奸你。处女们说，不，我们不想。所以鲁米尼亚维的人杀了她们所有人。你知道，如果鲁米尼亚维让我做某事，我会做的。我不会胡闹。我会说，是的，好的，随便。请不要把我变成鼓。所以西班牙人严重丢脸了。
and they will rape you if you don't. And the virgins said, no, we don't want to. So Ruminow's men killed them all. Do you know, if Rumini told me to do something, I would do it. I'm not going to mess around. I'm going to go, yes, fine, whatever. Please don't turn me into a drum. So then the Spanish disgraced themselves massively.
他们找不到宝藏。他们在当地乡村到处搜寻，寻找宝藏。他们找不到。他们开始屠杀所有的妇女和儿童，要求，你知道，黄金在哪里？即使是探险队的官方皇家编年史家也说这是残忍，不配做一个卡斯蒂利亚人。天哪，那是严厉的话。那是严厉的话。
They couldn't find the treasure. They sort of raid around the local countryside, are looking for the treasure. They can't find it. They start slaughtering all the women and children demanding, you know, where is the gold? Even the official royal chronicler of the expedition said this was cruelty, unworthy of a Castilian. God, that is stern words. There's are stern words.
实际上，如果你是厄瓜多尔人，你认为事情很暗淡，但现在事情会变得更糟。因为迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗和佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多都在迅速向厄瓜多尔心脏地带推进。所以阿尔马格罗先到达，实际上他按照自己的标准表现得相当好。不幸的是，莫尔伯勒学院的佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多的故事完全不同。因为他绝对丢脸了。即使按照他以前的标准。所以基本上，在他离开海岸后，他在丛林里完全迷路了。他的手下在丛林中砍出一条路，受到昆虫的攻击，被疾病蹂躏。
And actually, if you're Ecuadorian, you think things are bleak, but now things are going to get a lot worse. Because both Diego de El Magero and Pedro de Alvarado are fast advancing on the Ecuadorian heartland. So Almagro arrived first and actually he behaved himself by his own standards quite well. Unfortunately, it's a very different story with Marlborough College's Pedro de Alvarado. Because he has absolutely disgraced himself. Even by his previous standards. So basically, after he left the coast, he got completely lost in the jungle. His men were hacking their way through the jungle being attacked by insects and ravaged by disease.
他们所有的东西在潮湿中生锈。他们被困在火山喷发中，被灰烬覆盖。他们被灰烬覆盖。他们说，来吧，你知道，别抱怨了。曼科。他们穿过丛林。他们出现在安第斯山脉。然后他们走错了路。
All their stuff rusts in the humidity. They're caught in a volcanic eruption and covered with ash. They're covered with ash. They say, come on, you know, stop complaining. Manor. They get through the jungle. They emerge into the Andes. Then they go the wrong way.
他们的所有东西都在潮湿的环境中生锈了。他们遭遇了火山爆发，被火山灰覆盖。他们被火山灰覆盖了。他们说，得了吧，你知道，别抱怨了。庄园。他们穿过了丛林。他们出现在安第斯山脉。然后他们走错了方向。
And they go up the highest mountain pass into the Andes. So they're wading through snow drifts covered with snow. 85 Spaniards died of exposure or hypothermia because they've gone the wrong way in this mountain pass. But just as that bloke in Panama had predicted, all of the Guatemalans and Alvarado's native porters and a huge mob of female camp followers literally freeze to death as well. It's classic Alvarado. It is. They've all died. He hasn't died, however. He finally approaches Kito where he finds the other Spaniards waiting for him. And basically everybody thinks there's going to be this huge inter-Spanish battle. But one of them blinks. And do you know what?
他们翻越了安第斯山脉最高的山口。他们深一脚浅一脚地走在积雪覆盖的雪堆中。85名西班牙人因为走错了山口，死于暴露或体温过低。但正如那个在巴拿马的家伙所预言的那样，所有的危地马拉人、阿尔瓦拉多的土著搬运工以及一大群随军的女性也全都冻死了。这很阿尔瓦拉多。确实如此。他们都死了。不过他自己没死。他最终接近了基多，发现其他西班牙人正在那里等着他。基本上所有人都认为会有一场巨大的西班牙人之间的内战。但其中一人退缩了。你知道是什么吗？
this is a very poor advertisement for Tabby's old school because the person who blinks is Pedro. After all that, what's going on there? He's lost his bottle. He's completely lost his nerve. I think because he's covered with snow and volcanic ash. And he's killed all his people.
这对塔比的母校来说是个非常糟糕的广告，因为退缩的那个人是佩德罗。经历了这一切，那里到底发生了什么？他胆怯了。他完全失去了勇气。我想是因为他浑身覆盖着雪和火山灰。而且他杀光了他所有的人。
He's lost his mojo a little bit because basically he does a deal. He will sell all his ships and gear to Almagro for 100,000 gold pieces. All his men that he's come with them, the ones who are still left, will stay in Peru, work for the other Spanish generals. But he himself, Avarado, agrees that he will leave Peru and never come back.
他有点失去了斗志，因为他基本上达成了一笔交易。他将以10万金币的价格把所有的船只和装备卖给阿尔马格罗。他带来的所有手下，那些幸存者，将留在秘鲁，为其他西班牙将军工作。但他本人，阿尔瓦拉多，同意离开秘鲁，永远不再回来。
That is a shame. And he goes back to Guatemala, sort of in disgrace. And if people want to know what happened to him, his later life, there was a lot more sort of roistering around in Mexico and Central America, a lot of killing people and unnecessary cruelty. And he ended up dying in a very amusingly banal way. He died in 1541. and a freak accident and went out.
那真是太可惜了。他灰溜溜地回到了危地马拉。如果人们想知道他后来发生了什么，他晚年生活在墨西哥和中美洲，做了更多横行霸道的事，杀了不少人，还表现出不必要的残忍。他最终死于一种非常滑稽且平庸的方式。他死于1541年，一场离奇的事故让他丧命。
Horse sat on him, didn't he? Yeah, a horse fell on him. He had a very, a very impressive wife. Donia Louisa. The governor of Guatemala. Yeah. And I think she's in the entire history of the Spanish Empire in the Americas. She was the only female governor.
马坐在他身上了，对吧？是的，一匹马倒在他身上。他有一位非常令人印象深刻的妻子，多尼亚·路易莎。危地马拉的总督。是的。而且我认为在整个西班牙帝国在美洲的历史中，她是唯一一位女性总督。
Is that right? They're both buried in, I can't remember what it's called. Is it called Antigua or something like that in the old capital of Guatemala? I've often thought I'd like to go and see his grave. Tabby said she went and saw his portrait in Seville when she went to Seville. Good on Tabby.
是这样吗？他们都被埋葬在，我不记得叫什么名字了。是叫安提瓜还是类似的什么地方，在危地马拉的旧都？我经常想去看看他的坟墓。塔比说她去塞维利亚时看到了他的肖像。塔比做得好。
So that leaves two of the Spanish generals Al-Magro and Ben Al-Catha to deal with the northern warlords. So first of all, Kiskees. Kis has been trudging all the way out from Kusko with his colossal llamas. And does he know what's waiting for him?
所以这留下了两位西班牙将军阿尔马格罗和贝纳尔卡萨尔来对付北方的军阀。首先是基斯基斯。基斯基斯带着他庞大的羊驼群从库斯科一路跋涉而来。他知道有什么在等着他吗？
Not really. No, no he doesn't actually. So there's a bit of mountain pass, action, skirmishes and stuff, which we won't go into. basically eventually they emerge into southern Ecuador him and his men his men arrive in quito province to discover the Spanish have captured their capital they are gutted they can't believe it they thought they'd won the civil war you know a year ago or whatever and now they've got home to find that these weird bearded men have basically killed everybody and seized their own city they're distraught
并不真正知道。不，他确实不知道。所以有一些山口的战斗、小规模冲突之类的，我们就不细说了。基本上他们最终出现在厄瓜多尔南部，他和他的手下抵达了基多省，发现西班牙人已经占领了他们的首都。他们感到非常沮丧，简直不敢相信。他们以为一年前或者什么时候他们已经赢得了内战，现在回到家却发现这些奇怪的胡子男基本上杀光了所有人并夺取了他们的城市，他们悲痛欲绝。
and they go to kiskis and they say to him you know look general go and ask the Spanish for peace, quote, that they are invincible. And Kiskes says, you cowards, I would rather starve in the wilds than bend the knee and surrender my country. He reminds me of Shalda Gawl. And is he similarly successful? Does he emerge as the leader of a proud and independent Incan state? No.
他们去找基斯基斯，对他说，你看，将军，去向西班牙人求和吧，引用他们的话说，他们是不可战胜的。基斯基斯说，你们这些懦夫，我宁愿在荒野中饿死，也不愿屈膝投降，交出我的国家。他让我想起了沙尔达·高尔。他有同样的成功吗？他成为了一个骄傲且独立的印加国家的领导人了吗？没有。
But when he says that, his officers take out their clubs and they bludgeon him to death. So that's the end of him. John Heming says, it was a tragic end for one of the empire's finest generals. who passionately resented the menace and humiliation of the conquest. So I was sorry for him. He didn't turn anyone into a musical instrument. He led his men with great valor. He wouldn't surrender and he ended up on the wrong side of a club and that's sad.
但当他说出那番话时，他的军官们掏出棍棒，将他活活打死。所以这就是他的结局。约翰·赫明说，对于帝国最优秀的将军之一来说，这是一个悲惨的结局，他强烈地愤恨征服带来的威胁和羞辱。所以我为他感到难过。他没有把任何人变成乐器。他带着极大的勇气领导他的手下。他不愿投降，最终却死在了棍棒之下，这很可悲。
Okay, but the guy, I mean, kettle drum guy, he's still very much on the scene, isn't he? He is, but he's lost momentum too. A lot of his men desert. They think the Spanish can't be beaten. He's taken refuge in the mountains outside Quito. And at last, a conquistro called Miguel de la Tate. Chika gets a tip off that Rumiwaniawi is resting by a mountain lake. Quote,
好吧，但是那个家伙，我是说，定音鼓那个家伙，他仍然在现场，对吧？他是，但他也没了势头。他的许多手下逃跑了。他们认为西班牙人是不可战胜的。他在基多郊外的山区避难。终于，一个叫米格尔·德·拉·塔特的征服者得到消息说，鲁米尼亚维正在一个山湖边休息。引用：
When I reached the lake, the Lord Ruminiawi was beside a small hillock leaning against a tree. I closed with him, and after struggling for a very long time, I captured him. And so Rumi Nyawi is taken under guard back to Keto, where Sebastian de Bel Alcathar is in charge of interrogating him. Whether he's got his drum with him, I do not know. Does he have any gold? No. Has he got a drum? got gold, what's the point of him?
当我到达湖边时，鲁米尼亚维大人正靠在一棵树旁的小土丘边。我靠近他，在经过长时间的搏斗后，我俘虏了他。于是鲁米尼亚维被押送回基多，塞巴斯蒂安·德·贝纳尔卡萨尔负责审问他。他是否带着他的鼓，我不知道。他有黄金吗？没有。他有鼓吗？有黄金，留着他有什么用？
I'd like to think he's still got his drum. But surely they allow him to get, because Atowalpa was allowed to keep the severed head of that bloke to use as a teapot or whatever. So surely this guy is allowed to keep his human drum. Anyway, they torture him, they burn him again, more singeing, where's the gold? No joy.
我倒希望他还有他的鼓。但他们肯定允许他保留，因为阿塔瓦尔帕被允许保留那个家伙的断头来当作茶壶之类的东西。所以肯定允许这个家伙保留他的人皮鼓。不管怎样，他们折磨他，再次烧他，更多的灼烧，黄金在哪里？毫无收获。
And at last, they bring him out 1535, June 1535, into the main square of Quito, and they execute Rumi Nyawi. I think they burn him as well. And the conquest of the north is complete. It's rapid. isn't it? Yeah.
最后，在1535年6月，他们把他带到基多的主广场，处决了鲁米尼亚维。我想他们也把他烧死了。对北方的征服完成了。这很快，不是吗？是的。
It's what? It's a year to conquer the whole thing and beat two armies. Yeah. Yeah. And a lot of it, I think, not because the Spanish overpowered people in battle, but they just, it's about morale. The Keaton's just sort of lost hearts. They thought they can never beat these folks with their horses.
是什么？用了一年时间征服了整个地区并击败了两支军队。是的。是的。而且我认为很大程度上不是因为西班牙人在战斗中压倒了对方，而是关于士气。基多人只是失去了信心。他们认为他们永远无法打败这些骑马的人。
Also, I guess, a key point. They've got tribal allies. The Caniari people, I mentioned, you mentioned the great enthusiasm, the Huancas. Yes. They've got various such people. What did we say in the Aztec series? Diversity is not their strength. So now you might think this is the end of the story, but you would be wrong.
另外，我想，一个关键点。他们有部落盟友。我提到的卡尼亚里人，你提到的充满热情的万卡人。是的。他们有各种这样的人。我们在阿兹特克系列中是怎么说的？多样性不是他们的力量。所以现在你可能认为这是故事的结局，但你错了。
Because back in Kusko, Manco has been surveying all this and thinking, this is not quite what I thought it would be. He's slightly riding a crocodile here? Yeah. Because clearly, you know, the Spanish had been melting down all this gold and silver all this time. It took them three months to do it. And then Pizarro shared it out. But the Spanish do not stop there.
因为在库斯科，曼科一直在观察这一切，心想，这和我想的不太一样。他在这里有点骑虎难下？是的。因为很明显，你知道，西班牙人一直在熔化所有的黄金和白银。他们花了三个月才完成。然后皮萨罗把它分了。但西班牙人并没有就此停止。
Now, every previous Spanish expedition to the new world had degenerated quite quickly. into disorder and feuding. And the conquest of Peru, I'm sorry to say, is no different. So in March 1934, Pizarro had refounded Cusco as a Spanish city under Spanish law. And at the time, Pizarro, to be fair to him, had directed that locals should be well treated. And I quote, the native people of this country were created as our brothers and our descendants of our first ancestors. I mean, that's the sort of message of the Las Casas school, isn't it, Tom? Yes.
现在，之前每一次前往新大陆的西班牙远征都很快堕落为混乱和内斗。我很遗憾地说，秘鲁的征服也不例外。所以在1534年3月，皮萨罗在西班牙法律下将库斯科重建为西班牙城市。当时，公平地说，皮萨罗曾指示应该善待当地人，我引用：这个国家的原住民是被创造出来作为我们的兄弟和我们祖先的后裔的。我的意思是，那是拉斯卡萨斯学派的信息，对吧，汤姆？是的。
that there are always people in the Spanish world who are saying, if we are true Christians, we cannot treat these people just as slaves and as dogs and all of this. We can't burn them and chain them up and execute them. We've got to treat them properly. We've got to be true to our principles. Yeah, but I mean, it never crosses their mind that turning up, nicking their city, turning it into something completely else. I mean, that's quite bad.
在西班牙世界里总有人说，如果我们是真正的基督徒，我们就不能把这些人仅仅当作奴隶和狗来对待。我们不能烧死他们、锁住他们并处决他们。我们必须正确对待他们。我们必须忠于我们的原则。是的，但我的意思是，他们从未想过，出现并窃取他们的城市，将其变成完全不同的东西。我的意思是，这相当糟糕。
Well, I think we think it's bad. They didn't think it was bad. They thought it was tremendous. Yeah. I know. But the problem I think is they don't even do the bare minimum. Because Pizarro's men are clearly disobeying him, and we know this because he's having to send out constant instructions. Stop looting gold and silver from the local. Stop mistreating people. There's a story about a conquistador called Gonzalo Maldonado, who ignores him, he imprisons the high priest of Kusko and says, I won't let you out until he give me gold and silver.
嗯，我想我们认为这很糟糕。他们不认为这很糟糕。他们认为这太棒了。是的。我知道。但我认为问题在于他们甚至没有做到最低限度。因为皮萨罗的手下显然在违抗他，我们知道这一点是因为他不得不不断发出指令。停止从当地人那里掠夺金银。停止虐待人民。有一个关于一个叫贡萨洛·马尔多纳多的征服者的故事，他无视皮萨罗，囚禁了库斯科的大祭司，并说，除非你给我金银，否则我不放你出来。
And Pizarro basically has to threaten to execute this guy to force him to release the high priest. It would still have been possible, surely, for the people of Kusko, the native people, to rise up and wipe these people out. Yeah, but at this point, Manco, and therefore the elite, are on their side. On their side. Because, of course, at this point, they are still using the Spaniards in their own minds to conquer the North. And this is what's changing in Manco's mind. And I suppose also what is starting to happen at the same time is that all these guys who've been told, brilliant, there's loads of gold out in Peru, who've been coming.
皮萨罗基本上不得不威胁要处决这个家伙，才迫使他释放了大祭司。对于库斯科的人民，原住民来说，起义并消灭这些人肯定还是有可能的。是的，但在这一点上，曼科以及精英阶层站在他们这一边。站在他们这一边。因为当然，在这一点上，他们心目中仍然在利用西班牙人来征服北方。这就是曼科思想中正在改变的东西。我想同时开始发生的事情是，所有那些被告知秘鲁有大量黄金、从西班牙赶来的人开始出现。开始出现。所以这是一件大事。整个西班牙帝国其他地区的殖民官员，也就是加勒比海、中美洲，已经在写信给西班牙说，将不会剩下任何人了。来自秘鲁的消息太惊人了，以至于老老少少都在收拾行装去那里。除非把他们绑住，否则我们一个公民都不会剩下。这是来自波多黎各的消息。
coming from Spain are starting to turn up. I'm beginning to turn up. So this is a huge thing. The colonial officials across the rest of the Spanish Empire, that's the Caribbean, Central America, are already writing to Spain and saying, there's going to be nobody left. The news from Peru is so extraordinary that old and young men alike are packing up to go there. Unless they're tied down, we won't have a single citizen left. That's from Puerto Rico.
所以有大量的此类信件。现在海岸上有这么多人到达，以至于皮萨罗决定我们要建立一个新的基地。在海岸上，在海岸上建立一座新城市。他在1535年1月选定了一个地点。他想把它命名为国王之城，Thurudad de los Rheyes。但最终它以一个当地的神谕命名，在克丘亚语中被称为说话者，
So there are loads of such letters. And there are so many people arriving on the coast now that Pizarro decides we're going to build a new base. on the coast, a new city on the coast. And he picks a site in January 1535. He wants to call it the city of the kings, Thurudad de los Rheyes. But it ends up being called after a local oracle, which in Quechua was called the Speaker,
或者利马，与此同时，正如你正确指出的那样，汤姆，所有这些人都在出现，他们想要点什么。现在黄金已经被分配了，所以皮萨罗给他们的是土地。他分发了大量的土地。西班牙人的土地，整个村庄，成千上万的劳工。如果你是一个定居者，你会住在西班牙城镇里的西班牙联排别墅里，这是秘鲁的一个西班牙基础，
or Lima, now meanwhile, all these people, as you correctly say, Tom, are turning up, and they want something. Now the gold's being distributed, so what Pizarro is giving them is land. He is giving out huge tracts of land. of Spaniards, entire villages, thousands of labourers. What you would do, if you were a settler, you would live in a Spanish townhouse, Spanish built in a Spanish town, a Spanish foundation in Peru,
但你会得到城镇外巨大的土地庄园，你会得到成百上千的工人。因为记住，在此之前没有私有财产。没有私营企业。基本上是强迫劳动。你会得到成千上万被称为印第安人的人，他们有义务定期向你进贡。这就是西班牙人从一开始就在新大陆实行的监护征赋制。是的，特别是在墨西哥。而且这非常容易被滥用。
but you would be given huge landed estates outside the town, and you would be given hundreds or thousands of workers. Because remember, there was no private property before this. There was no private enterprise. There was basically enforced labour. You would be given thousands of called Indians who are obliged to deliver regular tribute to you. So this is the encomienda set up that the Spanish have been practicing in the new world since the very beginning. Yes, especially in Mexico. And which is so open to abuse.
没错。这是，我讨厌使用术语，因为我通常不喜欢使用术语，但人们谈论定居者殖民主义。如果你想要一个非常好的掠夺性定居者殖民主义的例子，这是一个很好的例子。实际上，皇家官员正在告诉皮萨罗停止。停止分发别人的土地。所谓的印第安人是王权下的自由西班牙臣民。把他们给别人不是你的职责。但其他征服者一直对他说，我们需要更多的土地。如果他想保持他作为老大的地位，他就必须安抚他们。这对皮萨罗来说是个大问题。更大的问题是对于
Exactly. It is, I hate to use the jargon because I don't like using jargon generally, but people talk of settler colonialism. And if you want a really good example of extractive settler colonialism, this is a very good one. And actually royal officials are telling Pizarro stop. Stop giving out other people's lands. The Indians, so-called, are free Spanish subjects under the crown. It's not your place to give them to people. But the other conquistadors keep saying to him, we want more land. And if he wants to keep his position as top dog, he has to appease them. It's a big problem for Bizarro. Bigger problem for
曼科来说。如果年轻的曼科，年轻的皇帝，在宫殿里看着这一切，他会想，会想，发生了什么？我的帝国在我周围被分掉了。他的地位当然极其不稳定。他很年轻。发生了一场内战。你知道，有一种日益增长的感觉，他是一个西班牙傀儡。他的宫殿里一直有投诉传来。西班牙人在乡下表现得很糟糕。他们在奴役人民。他们在洗劫村庄。他们在寻找黄金。然后在1535年夏天，发生了两件绝对灾难性的事情。其中一个皮萨罗兄弟看上了曼科的妹妹，她也是他的妻子，
Manco, though. If young Manco, the young emperor, is watching this in his palace, he is thinking, thinking, what's happening? My empire has been given away around me. His position, of course, is incredibly insecure. He's young. There's been a civil war. You know, there's a growing sense that he's a Spanish puppet. There are complaints coming in to his palace all the time. The Spanish are behaving badly in the countryside. They're enslaving people. They're raiding villages. They're searching for gold. And then in the summer of 1535, two things happen that are absolutely disastrous. one of the Pizarro brothers takes a fancy to Manko's sister who is also his wife
其次，皮萨罗兄弟和迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗之间的不和达到了沸点。下次我们将讨论曼科召集他的人民进行战争，库斯科之战，美洲历史上最伟大的围攻之一。皮萨罗最黑暗的时刻，以及他与前商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗不和的血腥高潮。所以还有很多内容要讲。Restis历史俱乐部的成员现在当然可以听到那一集。如果你想加入他们，如果你想加入我们Restis历史俱乐部的特别优惠，
and secondly the feud between the Pizarro brothers and Diego de al-Magro reaches boiling point and what we'll be talking about next time Manko summons his people to war the battle for Cusco one of the greatest sieges in the history of the Americas Pizarro's darkest hour and the bloody climax of his feud with his form business partner, Diego de Al-Magro. So still so much to come. And Restis History Club members can hear that episode right now, of course. And if you would like to join them, if you would like to pile in to the Cusco of our special offer in the Restis History Club,
那么你可以去RestisHistory.com并在那里进行操作。但现在，再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
then you can go to the Restis History.com and do so there. But for now, goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。